All right. What's up, YouTube? As
always, welcome to another live stream.
I'm super excited for tonight's show.
Um, we're going to be getting into some
really serious theology tonight. Uh, and
this is actually going to kick off where
the content on the channel is headed
over the next few weeks. You're going to
need to buckle up tonight as this will
be a heavyweight stream. It'll be uh
about an hour and a half to two hours.
We're not going to do Q&A tonight. What
I mean by heavyweight is there's going
to be a lot of meat here. So, buckle up
and pay close attention. I have with me
James from the YouTube channel Academy
Apologia. And we're going to be
discussing and examining the gospel and
Jesus of 7th Day Adventism and whether
or not both of those things are actually
in bounds of Orthodox Christianity. Uh I
would say that these are the two most
important topics when it comes to the
Christian faith. These are the cardinal
doctrines. Who is Christ and what is the
gospel? Uh in the words of Paul the
Apostle in Galatians 1 6-9, he says,
"I'm astonished that you were so quickly
deserting him who called you in the
grace of Christ and are turning to a
different gospel. Not that there is
another one, but there are some who
trouble you and want to distort the
gospel of Christ. But even if we,
meaning the apostles themselves, or an
angel from heaven should preach to you a
gospel contrary to the one that we
preach to you, let him be accursed. As
we have said before, so now I say again,
a double curse. If anyone is preaching
to you a gospel contrary to the one you
received, let him be accursed. Paul
continues to say in Galatians that he
did not receive this gospel from man,
but from Jesus Christ himself. The same
Paul in 2 Corinthians 11:3-4 said,
quote, "But I am afraid that as the
serpent deceived Eve by this cunning,
your thoughts will be led astray from a
sincere and pure devotion to Christ. For
if anyone comes and proclaims another
Jesus than the one we proclaimed,
meaning there are other Jesuses, or if
you receive a different spirit from the
one you received, or if you accept a
different gospel from the one you
accepted, you put up with it readily. So
Paul's concern for the churches at
Corenth was that they would tolerate a
different Jesus, a different spirit, and
a different gospel. And he told the
churches at Galatia that if anyone comes
preaching a different gospel than the
one revealed by Jesus Christ to the
apostles, let them be accursed. So as I
said, this makes it clear that there are
false gospels and there are false
Jesuses. Simply saying the name Jesus
does not cut it. The details matter. Who
is he? What exactly is the gospel? If
you are off on this, you are lost. A
false Christ and a false gospel cannot
save you. So consider this a trigger
warning. Tonight's stream is not going
to be kid glove stuff. The same Paul
that told the churches in Galatia that
he hopes that the Judaizers who crept in
trying to intermingle circumcision, a
work with the gospel, that he hopes that
their hand slips, this is in the fourth
chapter, and they emasculate themselves,
which is not very soft language from the
inspired apostle. So understand that
sometimes tough love is what is needed.
We want SDAs to come and know the truth.
We do not hate you. We also want the
wider body of Christ to be equipped to
reach Adventists with the truth. Having
grown up in the SDA church, I wish
someone would have been upfront and
honest with me about the theological
dangers of Adventism. There are plenty
of other people out there doing the
soft, and that's fine. There's a time
and a place for that. James and I are
people who shoot it straight. There was
never any challenging going on when I
was in the SDA world. It was one big
kumbaya around the fire as though
everything is just hunky dory when it
isn't. It isn't. So, as I mentioned,
James from the Academy Apology YouTube
channel is with me. James has been a
Christian since 1990. In 1993, he began
ministry uh doing outreach and study of
the Jehovah's Witnesses. By 1997, his
study and outreach expanded to include
many other groups such as Seventh Day
Adventists, Mormons, the Church of
Christ, Islam, Chrisadelfians, Children
of God, and others. He continues his
study of non-Christian religions and is
active in street and online evangelism.
He has an MA in business and an MA in
humanities. His thesis topic was a
historical view and analysis of English
Qurans from 1649 to 2005. Interesting
topic. uh he is currently an adjunct
college professor at uh the at
university and he is a continuing
education instructor as well. So with
that said, brother, thank you for being
here. Hey, well, thanks for having me.
Totally. Like I said, I am really
excited about tonight's stream. As um
you and I both know, this is a very
important topic. Um and I wanted to
stress that there in the beginning. Um,
the audience is going to be about 16 I
think it's about 16 seconds or so delay
behind us. Um, so if you're keeping up
with comments and stuff in the side
chat, which you can check out, um,
they'll be a little bit behind where
we're at. But, um, tell the audience why
a stream like this is necessary. Isn't
Seventh Adventism just another Christian
denomination with a couple of minor
differences? Yeah, that's a very common
notion, I'd say, out there in the
Christian world or even non-Christian
world. Seventh Day Adventists, they um
they're not, you know, they're not the
wildeyed, crazy, bombthrowing people
that would make somebody say, "Well,
they're odd and strange. They would be
good neighbors. They dress nice. They
talk nice. They go to church, maybe on a
different day, but they do."
But what the average person doesn't
realize, and and I realize this more and
more even on my YouTube channel or even
with the friends that I interact with
around me, is that they have a complete
misconception of who the 7th Day
Adventist organization is. And they
think just that. They think they're just
Saturday going Christians. And I say,
"No, here's the difference. When you
have a different Jesus, like you said
earlier in your introduction, and you
have a different gospel, you are indeed
in trouble. And what I'll even say about
the 7th Day Adventist, and I was
thinking about this and took some notes,
is they have a though they don't say
this often, they have a
thought of exclusiveness. We are the
religion. We are the remnant. Now,
Seventh Day Adventists like to say,
"Well, we're not the remnant. There are
remnant people and other rel." It's
like, "No, no. I've got your magazines.
Read it." It uses definite article the
remnant. And even so much as to say that
they that they say they are God's chosen
representatives. And I'm quoting now
from an from an actual magazine. So, the
other buzzword the other buzzword being
God's last day church. Yes. Exactly.
Yeah. Yeah. That's probably more more
used than than even that is that last
day church. And I want and and I want to
say this that they do all that I've said
with deception.
And and here's what I mean by that. And
I'm actually looking at a quote from
Ministry magazine that I really like in
1981.
Ron Grey Bill, right? Who we can still
see on YouTube today. Yeah. And he and
he said this in in in in talking in in
engaging the Sunday keepers, right, the
large church. She says, "Only if we
refrain from Ellen White as a normative
authority for doctrine can we hope to
meet other Christians on common ground."
So do you hear if we refrain from So in
other words, let's not bring let's not
this is I call this the hide Ellen
quote. So we're not going to talk about
Ellen White refrain from using her. Then
we hope we can meet Christians on other
common ground. That's deception. And and
7th Day Adventism does a lot of
deception. And again, I mean, another
quote comes to mind where they say that
they they are the only Bible Protestants
in the world today. Now, they said that
like 120 years ago, right? And so, even
what I see today in 2022,
uh, and what they did a 100 years ago,
it's still the same message. It may not
be something that's verbalized as often
by the average Adventist,
but it's hiding in plain sight. just
read their literature and and it's
there. So no, the average Christian does
not understand the seventh day
Adventists have a different Christ and a
different gospel. And because of that,
you know, the consequences I often say
are are severe and eternal. And you
know, Matthew Matthew chapter 7, not
everyone who says to me, Lord, Lord, is
going to enter the kingdom of heaven.
And at the end of that, Christ there's
there's going to be no appeal in this
court. Christ is going to say, "Go away
from me. I never knew you." And much
like you said, it's knowing the right
Christ. Yeah. Because there are clearly
people in that scenario who think they
know the Christ. And he's like, well,
and not just that, James, if you pay
close attention to what he says, he
says, "Depart from me, you workers of
iniquity. I never knew you." Right? If
you parallel that with Galatians,
uh Paul says, uh something to the effect
of um now that you know God or rather
are known by him, being known by God is
is not a term do in God's omniscience.
Obviously, God being omnisient knows
that you exist. That's not what's being
said. It's a salvific term. So the
people that are turned away there in
Matthew 7, Christ never knew them
because they had a false Christ. That's
exactly right.
So, in in your experience,
because I've been not always at a
necessarily I I I had a very uh cage
stage at my early conversion. Um, and so
I was a lot more wound up and zealous
than uh I am now. So, Adventist, if you
think I'm worked up now, um talk to the
SDAs that I engaged with uh when I first
got saved. Uh but I've been doing this
for for quite some time. And the
constant thing that I found, James, and
I want to know your take on this, um, as
somebody who has engaged with a lot of
Seventh Day Adventists, I don't run into
a lot of people who have engaged with a
lot of Adventists unless they're an
Adventist. Mhm. So, in my experience, I
can tell you out of the hundreds of SDAs
that I've talked to,
only two of them who understood the
gospel. Wow. There are those who will
give me the lip service. It's that
Christ died for our sins. When you start
getting into the details, how are you
reconciled to God? What do I need saved
from? What is sin? These finer details
that you really do have to get into.
It's not good news if you don't know the
bad news. So, walking through the bad
news and really understanding what the
bad news is, getting into those details.
Of course, I get the the I know what the
gospel is and they just throw out the
cross of Christ. Um, well, right, but
you guys don't believe that the
atonement was Well, okay. So, then the
ball starts rolling. Now you're talking
about a different atonement. And we're
going to get into all that stuff
tonight, but I want to know what your
experience has been engaging with
Seventh Day Adventists. How many of them
understand the gospel? None.
Literally none. It is like you say, I'll
get those few who will and and I think
in Adventism I've come to to realize
they like to use whatever they think
Christian sounding words are that appeal
to a broader evangelical community. So
they'll use dictionary. Yeah. But but
but that's as deep as they go. um
they'll throw out the big fluffy words,
but when you start asking them or
showing them um what their own
literature teaches, that's it. They're
they're done. They really don't know
what to do at that point. Now, this is
something that that I find interesting.
I'll I'll I'll meet with Adventist and
and I'll and I'll you know, you have a
different gospel, you have a different
Christ. They say, "No, we don't." And
then I'll start showing them material,
books, and etc. Say, "Well, let's look
here." And then I show it to them
and and then and then you know what they
do is while they denied it two minutes
ago, then I show them in their
literature and then they start now
they're defending it. I say, "Whoa,
whoa, whoa. You just told me you didn't
even know what it was and now you're
defending that which you do not know.
How does that work?" Because really how
it works is the we are going to defend
Adventism to the death. Yeah. And if
that means sacrificing Bible truth,
which they do all the time, we will
defend Adventism to the death. So when
it comes to the gospel like you just
asked for, yeah, they they largely don't
know what it is. Most Adventists know
what the three angels messages are.
Maybe they can't articulate an in-depth
explanation of all three angels, but
they have a really good high-level
overview, and they at least understand
that and that's a good basis upon which
to launch off into a conversation with
the biblical gospel. Yep. So, that's
what we're going to do. Now, um I I want
to talk about before we get into the
Adventist gospel. So, what we're going
to do tonight, folks, is we are going to
compare the biblical gospel to the
Adventist gospel. Then, we are going to
compare the biblical Christ to the
Adventist Christ. Let the chips fall
where they may. So, brother, I'm going
to bring up
1 Corinthians 15 here. And if you could
for us, could you please read verses uh
1 through 8?
All right. Now I make known to you,
brothers, the gospel which I proclaimed
as good news to you, which also you
received in which you stand, and by
which you are also saved, if you hold
fast the word which I proclaimed to you
as good news, unless you believe for
nothing. For I deliver to you as the
first importance what I also received,
that Christ died for our sins according
to the scriptures, that he was buried,
and that he was raised on the third day
according to the scriptures, and that he
appeared to Cphus, and then to the 12,
and that he appeared to more than 500
brothers at one time, most of whom
remain until now, but some have fallen
asleep. After that, he appeared to James
and then to all the apostles. And last
of all, to one ultimately born, he
appeared to me also.
This is the gospel in a nutshell. That's
it. You obviously have to get into the
finer details around again sin and those
sorts of things. But this is a cliffnote
presentation from scripture of the
gospel that Christ died according to the
scriptures that he was buried. That he
was raised on the third day according to
those scriptures which was was
prophesied and foretold.
And that after that he appeared to
numerous people
and at one point more than 500 brothers
at one time, most of whom were still
alive but some had died. And then after
that he appeared to James and to all the
apostles and last of all as to one
untimely born Paul speaking he appeared
to him. And we have that documented in
Acts chapter nine.
So
how is one reconciled brother? This is
what I want to look at next
because when we talk about
reconciliation,
how a person's made right before God,
how a person is seen as righteous,
this is the real crux of the matter with
the SDAs when it comes to to to well,
it's one of the crux issues when it
comes to the SDAs. How is a person seen
as righteous?
Sorry tonight to my Roman Catholic
viewers, but when we're on my channel,
we're coming from it from my theology.
The 7th Day Adventist view of how a
person is seen as righteous before God
is no different fundamentally. And we
talked about this earlier
from medieval Roman Catholicism.
Their system of sotiology and how a
person is seen as righteous, which is
part of the gospel,
is essentially medieval Roman
Catholicism. It is a two-tiered system
of justification.
You are justified, declared righteous
before God. It's not like Romanism in
that sense. They wouldn't define
justified that way. But the Adventists
would say you're justified before God by
faith alone, of course.
But then your justification is continued
essentially based on your obedience to
the law.
You retain your justification by your
obedience. It is not like Paul's going
to say here, which we're going to get
into
that you are declared righteous by God
by your faith alone before you do
anything. And then obedience will
naturally follow afterward because God
being the author of your salvation will
continue the work that he's already
started in sanctifying you. And there'll
be good days, there will be bad days.
The Christian now has a desire to war
with their sin and follow the Lord Jesus
Christ. And you're not immediately
perfect. You're not sanctified to 100%
on day one. It is a process over your
life where the spirit begins a work
within you. But that does not retain
one's justification. Your good works
does not retain your salvation. But
that's what the seventh adventist system
teaches. So if you could, can you read
verse nine there for me? Well, actually
see what he Let's Let's let's go back
because he quotes um David here. Start
in verse 5 and read to verse uh nine if
you would. Okay. But to the one who does
not work but believes upon him who
justifies the ungodly, his faith is
counted as righteousness. Just as David
also speaks of the blessing on the man
to whom God counts righteousness apart
from works. So pause real quick.
And then he says, "Oh, go ahead. What
does this what does this tell us
about a person being seen as righteous
before God
in regards to where he's now quoting
from. This is hundreds of years before.
So the this idea don't I'm just saying
this to to say don't people don't try
and say well this was then this is now
present truth or any of that sort of
stuff. We have a consistent thing here.
The reason he's quoting from David is
because that corresponds to what he's
about to say about Abraham and himself
and new covenant believers. It's the
same thing for all of us. So continue
now. All right. Verse 7. Blessed are
those whose lawless deeds have been
forgiven and whose sins have been
covered. Blessed is a man whose sin the
Lord will not take into account.
Therefore, is this blessing on the
circumcised or on the uncircumcised
also? For we say faith was counted to
Abraham as righteousness.
How then was it? Oh, go ahead. So, go
ahead. Well, so he's we can we were
going to stop there real quick. Um, so
this he makes a compare and contrast
here when he talks about the circumcised
and the uncircumcised. He's talking
about Jews and Gentiles.
Is this blessing on the circumcised or
on the uncircumcised? Also, he then goes
into talking about Abraham who was part
of the uncircumcision party. Israel's
not born yet.
And he goes into explaining that
Abraham's faith is what counted him
righteous. He's quoting from Genesis 15
here.
Abraham believed God and it was credited
him as righteousness. Paul goes in to
explain in the next verses here, how
then was it counted while he was
circumcised or uncircumcised. So before
he had done any work or after he had
done work.
Circumcision is a work. Not while
circumcised but while uncircumcised. And
he received the sign of circumcision.
Here's the key. as a seal of the
righteousness of the faith which he had
while uncircumcised,
so that he might be the father of all
who believe without being circumcised,
that righteousness might be counted to
them, and the father of circumcision to
those who are not uh those who not only
are of the circumcision, the Jews, but
who also follow in the steps of the
faith of our father Abraham, which he
had while uncircumcised.
Before Abraham did anything, he was seen
as righteous by his faith.
That is how a person is seen as
righteous before God. He continues on
talking about now how essentially um for
the promise of Abraham is to the seed
and it would be heirs of the world was
not through the law but through the
righteousness of faith. another phrase
Adventist love and then import their own
definition into um but he basically
continues on into what I want to go to
which is chapter five because now we see
a person is seen as righteous before God
by their faith alone when they believe
when they trust God it doesn't mean that
the person will not walk out in good
works it doesn't mean that no good works
are will follow neither of us here are
advocating for cheap grace I got my
ticket punched no change in a person's
life we're not advocating that tonight.
But there is a clear delineation between
how a person is seen righteous and their
obedience and the two are not
intermingled what would be called like a
law gospel m intermingling. There's a
distinction between the two. But he
continues after explaining this saying,
"Therefore, having been justified by
faith, we have peace with God through
our Lord Jesus Christ, through whom also
we have obtained an introduction by
faith into this grace in which we stand.
And we boast in hope of the glory of
God. And not only this, but we also
boast in our afflictions, knowing that
affliction brings about perseverance,
and perseverance, proven character, and
proven character hope. And hope does not
put to shame because the love of God has
been poured out within our hearts
through the Holy Spirit who was given to
us. For while we were still weak at the
right time, Christ died for the ungodly.
For one will hardly die for a righteous
person, though perhaps for the good man
someone would dare even to die. But God
demonstrates his own love toward us in
that while we were yet sinners, Christ
died for us. much more than having been
justified by his blood, we shall be
saved from the wrath of God through him.
For if while we were enemies, we were
reconciled to God through the death of
his son, much more having been
reconciled, we shall be saved by his
life. And not only this, but we also
boast in God through our Lord Jesus
Christ, through whom we have now
received the reconciliation.
James, how is somebody reconciled to God
according to what we just read from
chapter four and five? Yeah, you know,
it's simple.
I think of the Philippian jailer. Amen.
And his experience, and for those of you
that that may not know, in in short, the
Apostle Paul is in jail. There's an
earthquake and the walls fall down. And
the uh custom of the time is if you're a
jailer and someone escapes, you're dead.
Mhm. And so the the jailer was fretting.
This is Acts 16. And so the the jailer
was fretting. It's like, I'm going to
die now. Everybody's gone. The Apostle
Paul said, "No, no, no. We're still
here." And the jailer, who had been
hearing the Apostle Paul and others
preach Christ and him crucified, said,
"What must I do to be saved?" And what
was the Apostle Paul's response? Believe
in the Lord Jesus Christ. And you That's
it. Exactly what you just read. And as
you're reading that, I am contrasting
that with a with a completely opposite
picture. Yeah. Which I can paint in
Seventh Day Adventism in that that's not
how you're saved. I am uh I'm I'm in the
process of thinking about doing another
video. I was doing some research and in
this research I kept stumbling across in
early 7th day Adventist literature uh
new converts of 7th day Adventism. And
you know how new converts to seventh day
Adventism are described. Not what we
just read as coming to Christ through
faith, but keeping the Sabbath.
And I I knew that and I don't even know
what you're talking about in terms of
what document it is. I've read this
exactly right dozens if not hundreds of
times when I was doing research and
going through PDF magazines of Review
and Heralds. We went to the town of, you
know, Dirtwater, Texas, and 25 souls
committed to keeping the Sabbath. I
mean, that kind of language is over and
over and over. And then just last week,
I was doing some other unrelated search
and I came across obituaries.
And I, you know what I found? Exactly
the same thing. Sister Sally died at 85
years old, but she's been keeping the
Sabbaths, you know, for 63 years. That's
the seal. not that she had faith in
Christ. And I thought, you know, here we
are at the very beginning about them
keeping the Sabbath. And I read the
obituaries, it's about keeping the
Sabbath. And very rarely, if ever, do I
read about it's faith in Christ. And
even then, the Adventist Jesus is not
the Jesus of the Bible. And so, yeah, as
we're reading this, I'm I'm thinking of
reconciliation and a Seventh Day
Adventist. It's a Sabbath. And if any
and again if any events wants to
challenge me on that, challenge me. I've
got the magazines. I got the sources. I
I I have another quote. Let me let me
just scroll down and look at it here.
1931. It says this. It is this
transgression of the ten commandments
that must be atoned for by the blood.
1 Corinthians 15:3
says that Christ died for our sins,
not the Ten Commandments.
You know what else is interesting about
that, brother? H Hebrews 1:3,
if you look at the the literal
translation of that from the Greek,
Yeah. it's that Christ has already made
purification or cleansing Yes. for sin.
Oh, yes. and has now seated. He's
seated. Now, that's something the
Levitical priest, they're so caught up
on trying to look for parallels in
Hebrews, for example, and they miss the
vast differences.
Christ is already cleansed with sin. But
continue what you were saying. Oh, yeah.
No, no. I mean, I mean, I mean, that was
it. I mean, as you're thinking, and
we've just read the scriptures, you are
saved through faith in Christ. It's not
lawkeeping. It's not whatever religion
you came from, whatever it is you got,
it's faith in Christ. Just read what the
Philippian jailer did and what he was
told to do. That's it. Yeah. But like I
said, yet when I read Adventist
magazines, it's like I I think from
cradle to grave. Literally from cradle
to grave. They are boasting of
Sabbathkeeping. Yeah. um I mean that's
what I read in obituaries and that's
what I read in u their praise reports of
their new converts. It's Sabbathkeeping.
And then this last quote I read which is
uh Christ uh it's the transgression of
the ten commandments that must be atoned
for. And the Bible clearly doesn't say
Christ died for the ten commandments. He
died for our sins. Again 1 Corinthians
15:3 part of the gospel message. Well,
that's stemming from their which is that
quote is essentially just downstream
from their whole concept and idea that
Christ died to vindicate the Ten
Commandments because when they say the
law, they mean the Ten Commandments and
that's all just ultimately downstream of
this whole pre-earth origin story. They
sound like Mormonism in that very much.
that. So now that we have that laid out
there, that is in a nutshell. Well, I
want to look at one other sorry I want
to look at one other couple set of
verses here because this again is
another key because Paul is making a
compare and contrast here regarding
if anyone has uh room to boast Paul
essentially says it's him because he
says although I myself have confidence
even in the flesh if anyone else has a
mind to put confidence in the flesh I
far more circumcised the eighth of the
nation of Israel, of the tribe of
Benjamin, a Hebrew of Hebrews as to the
law, a Pharisee as to the as to zeal, a
persecutor of the church, as to the
righteousness which is in the law, found
blameless. So he essentially lays out
that if anyone has room to boast, it's
me. But he continues, but whatever
things were gained to me, those things I
have counted as loss for the sake of
Christ. more than that. So all those
works, all those accolades, all those
things,
he's counted as lost for the sake of
Christ. Christ, not Sabbath. You think
Paul as a Jew is keeping the Sabbath,
Jim?
Not as a Christian. He's not. No, but as
a but as a Jew. Oh, as a Jew. Oh, yeah.
He Well, he tried. Yeah.
Well, the point is is that he's saying
if he has anything to boast in when it
comes to being of the circumcised party,
the Jews, he has room to boast. That
would mean that Paul was probably a
zealot when it came to the Sabbath. He
was a Hebrew of Hebrews as to the law, a
Pharisee, as to the zeal, a persecutor
of the church.
But he counts all that, including the
Sabbath, everything that came with it as
loss for Christ. Christ, Christ, Christ,
Christ. More than that, I count all
things to be loss because of the
surpassing value of knowledge. Christ
Jesus, my Lord, for whom I have suffered
the loss of all things.
Hearkening back to, if you read in Acts,
being shipwrecked, he goes through this
list of things. Lashed all these times.
They stoned him two times trying to kill
him. thought he was dead one time.
More than that, I count all things to be
lost because of the surpassing value of
knowing Christ Jesus my Lord for whom I
have suffered the loss of all things and
count them rubbish so that I may gain
again Christ and be found in him. This
phrase in him is regularly used
throughout scripture in the New
Testament. It's a salvific term being in
Christ. The book of Romans uses this
over and over and over. The book of
Galatians and Colossians being found in
Christ. That's how we're seen as we're
about to see right now. Not having a
righteousness of my own which is from
the law.
The law. Not having a righteousness
found by the law,
but that which is through faith in
Christ, the righteousness which is from
God upon faith, that I may know him and
the power of his resurrection and the
fellowship of his sufferings, being
conformed to his death.
Paul boasted in Christ.
Paul had a righteousness infused to him.
A righteousness that was given to him
that was not his own, an alien
righteousness, an imputed righteousness.
I've noticed that Adventists have gotten
a lot more vocal about this here
recently, but typically they'll say
imputed and imparted,
which they know that person that's
saying that is they're two separate
things. Imputed is not the same as
imparted. Paul here is talking about a
foreign righteousness given to him. He
is then seen as righteous in Jesus
Christ. And how is that attained? James,
what does he say? By faith.
Faith in Christ. That's how.
So this is what the Bible teaches about
how a person is seen as righteous.
What the application of the gospel and
the good news looks like.
With that said, now let's talk about the
three angels gospel. The three angels
messages of the Adventist church. I'm
going to read a quote here
and then I'm going to have a question
for you. Okay. All right. For those that
are curious, this is from Letters and
Manuscripts, volume 11, manuscript 32,
paragraph 7. And for the Adventists out
there that are wondering, yes, I've read
this whole manuscript. I didn't just
quote mine this from Ellen
Whiteisrong.com type sources.
quote, "Christ came to our world to
represent the character of God." What do
they call the character of God, James?
The law. So, this goes back to that
quote you were saying earlier. If you
understand this system of theology, you
understand what's being said here.
Christ came to our world to represent
the character of God as it is
represented in his holy law. For his law
is a transcript of his character.
Christ has both the law and the gospel.
The angel that proclaims the everlasting
gospel proclaims the law of God.
So already we're seeing a and this is
replete through all of their theology.
An inability to differentiate between
the law and the gospel. It would benefit
them really well. They love to cling to
Luther for solos scriptor Adventist. One
other area that you could delve into on
Luther if you want to do all that is his
law gospel distinction and the
understanding around the law and the
gospel. Old covenant, new covenant.
The angel that proclaims the everlasting
gospel proclaims the law of God. For the
gospel of salvation brings men to
obedience to the law whereby their
characters are formed after the divine
similitude. End quote. Jim, when they
use this phrase, the everlasting gospel,
when they quote Revelation 14, which is
where they're getting this phrase from,
and they latch on to that, how are they
defining this? Is it what we just
defined? Is that the everlasting gospel?
Well,
when I encounter Adventists and they
like to use everlasting gospel,
first of all, I I want to note that when
Adventists read everlasting gospel, they
think eternal gospel. Yep. It's two
different words. Um because I think
we're going to see later um uh you know,
a quote where they can't can't preach
the gospel of Noah, etc. Right. We're
going we're going to we're going to see
that later. I'm bringing that up right
now because they think the gospel
message is eternal. Well, no. You're
you're missing the point. The gospel
message, as Miles said earlier, was
given to the Apostle Paul. This is
Galatians chapter 1. I think it's verses
11 and 12 was given to the Apostle Paul
by revelation from the resurrected
Christ is where he got the gospel
message from. So when Adventists say
everlasting gospel, first of all, I I
think we need to come to understand that
the messages of the three angels are
nowhere defined in those words and are
nowhere defined in the entire book of
revelation. For that we have to go to
other sources to get it because it's not
in the Bible. What I just said was the
gospel message of the SDA is not in the
Bible and the words the everlasting
gospel is not the gospel message. It's a
phrase. It's a phrase that does not have
a definition in the Bible. It has a
definition in Adventist literature, but
not in the Bible. That they're porting
into the text. Yes. And then pointing to
Revelation 14 and saying, "See, but it
says three angels." Right. Right. But
you're porting in your own 19th century
definition. So, I want to read this
here. This is a review and herald
article from 19 uh 34, November 29,
1934.
This section of this review and herald
Herald article, for those that are
curious, this is an official publication
of the 7th Adventist Church to this day,
not just from back then. This title and
heading is the gospel message and the
gospel messenger, which you're going to
see is LG White. So down here, I have it
highlighted. I'm going to read. It's a
little bit here, but I want to read.
It's not really too bad if you were to
string it all out here, but I want to
read this whole section and then we're
going to come back and talk about what
we read. Maybe I'll stop. Oh, sorry.
Maybe I'll I'll stop along the way
depending on I don't have all this
memorized obviously, but it says, quote
here, this movement with which we are
connected stands for certain great
fundamental truths.
Here they are. the existence of God, the
inspiration of the Holy Scriptures,
salvation alone through the vicarious
sacrifice of the Lord Jesus, repentance,
regeneration, and the gift of
righteousness by faith, which is not
what people think it is, the work of the
Holy Spirit, the immutability of God's
law, the binding claims of the Bible
Sabbath. They love to do that. They love
to import the word Bible before things
as like an adjective to make it sound
like, well, this is just what the Bible
teaches.
The priestly ministry of Christ in the
heavenly sanctuary. The investigative
judgment now going on. The soon coming
of Christ to take his children home. The
doctrine of spiritual gifts. The
manifestation of the gift of prophecy in
the remnant church which is fundamental
belief number 18 now by the way. Life
only in Christ. Christian temperance.
This is essentially just going through
the fundamental beliefs. And other
leading important Bible doctrines. These
great truths constitute the everlasting
gospel message of this time.
Then it goes up here to the subheading
of the three-fold message. So this is
the three angels here folks to the
seventh day Adventist church has been
committed this message. The everlasting
gospel was preached by Noah, by Abraham,
by Paul and Peter, and by all the
prophets and apostles of past ages. It
was preached in the setting appropriate
to their day.
As you're going to see, this is going to
essentially be there's different
doctrines for different times in this
present truth.
They continue, "We cannot preach this
gospel message as Noah preached it or as
Paul or Luther gave it. It is for us to
preach it in the setting of God's great
three-fold message of Revelation 14.
Luther preached righteousness by faith
in the setting of the gospel message for
the 16th century. We must preach
righteousness by faith in the setting of
God's message for this time.
Let that soak in there, folks. We must
preach righteousness by faith. So, this
is in contrast to Luther, the way that
Luther preached righteousness by faith
in the setting of God's message for this
time. For those that don't know, this is
what is getting at present truth. Like
all these groups, the Mormons, Jehovah's
Witnesses, they all have their own
version of this. It's basically relative
truth. Um, but it's a message for this
time. We are told by the messenger of
the Lord, this is Ellen White, quote,
several have written to me inquiring if
the message of justification by faith is
the third angel's message. And I have
answered, it is the third angel's
message in verity. That's from Review
and Herald, April 1st, 1890. The Apostle
Paul preached of righteousness and
temperance and of a judgment to come. We
cannot preach the judgment of God as did
the apostle. We must preach the hour of
his judgment is come. That judgment is
now going forward. The great underlying
principles of these truths are the same,
but in our preaching, their application
must be made to present day conditions.
They continue down here into this next.
It's only a small blip of gap there, but
then I want to read this really quick,
James, before we talk about that.
Integrity of the message. So, what they
just said now, they're talking about the
integrity of it. We're going to talk
about the Lord's messenger or servant
again here, and we're going to read
three of her quotes that they have. Of
the integrity of our message, we are
told this by the servant of the Lord.
That's Ellen White. First quote, "The
way marks which have made us what we are
are to be preserved and they will be
preserved as God has signified through
his word and the testimony of his
spirit." That's for those that don't
know that's through the writings of
Ellen White. They say the Holy Spirit is
essentially the author behind both the
Bible and her writings. And it's now the
testimony of his spirit is couched
within the writings of Ellen White. He
calls upon us to hold firmly with the
grip of faith to the fundamental
principles that are based upon
unquestionable authority. That's from
special testimony series B number two
page 59. The third quote or second
quote. As a people who are to stand firm
on the platform of eternal truth that is
withtood test and trial, we are to hold
to the pure or sorry to the sure pillars
of our faith. The principles of truth
that God has revealed to us are the only
true foundation.
They have made us what we are. The lapse
of time has not lessened their volume.
That's from the same source above, but
page 51. And then the final one, no line
of truth that has made the 7th day
Adventist people what they are is to be
weakened. We have the old landmarks of
truth, experience, and duty. And we are
to stand firmly in the defense of our
princip of our principles in full view
of the world. Testimonies for the church
volume six page 17. So what did she say
there in the end James? They are to hold
fast to these old landmarks of truth and
to stand firmly in defense of their
principles in the full view of the
world. What were those up here? All
these doctrines that were given,
this is their mono covenant theology
essentially coming through as well as
we're going to see here in a little bit.
But I want to give you a second to talk.
What are your thoughts on all that?
Well, this is a this is a biblical
disaster on on on the screen. And and
here's why I say that. I I use this
quote occasionally and I term this quote
that that you gave when uh on the first
part of it. This is a confession by the
7th Day Adventist Church that they
preach a different gospel 100%. It's a
just an outright admission and
confession because they say we cannot
preach the gospel as Paul preached it.
But what did we read earlier? The
Apostle Paul says um and you quoted in
Galatians 1, if we or an angel or two
angels or three angels gives you a
gospel other than the one that we teach
that we proclaim to you, let him be
accursed. And then he says it again, let
him be accursed. Well, the Apostle Paul
got the gospel message in I think it's
AD 445.
Actually pinned it in 1 Corinthians
about 10 years later.
And now it's in our book called the
Bible, the inspired word of God. And
here's the 7th Day Adventist Church
saying, "We can't do that. We can't
preach that." But yet here I have in my
hand the 28 Beliefs book. And I'm
looking at page
197,
the mission to the remnant. You know
what they say? We don't preach a
different gospel.
And so, wait a second. How do you say I
don't preach a different gospel over
here, but then over here you say, "Well,
we preach something completely
different." Well, and not just that,
James, but what made real quick, what
made the gospel in Galatians 1 that was
false false?
Yeah. The addition present truth. Yeah.
Well, the addition to the gospel
message. Oh, yeah. Paul was addressing
the Judaizers in Galatia. Mhm. They were
trying to add circumcision, which is why
again Paul goes to went to great lengths
in Galatians 4 to say, "I hope these
people that are doing this, I hope their
hand slips and they emasculate the and
they they take the whole thing off."
Right? That's the length he went to say
by you twisting the gospel. They added
one thing. One thing. What we read
earlier is far more than one thing. Some
of those things, yes, they're true, but
mixed in with that is a lot of stuff
that the apostles were not preaching.
Continue. You you heard Adventists say,
and I'm sure you've you've encountered
this, too. You'll have a conversation
like we're having with the Seventh Day
Adventist. You show them from their
literature what the three angels message
is. You show them from the Bible what
the Bible message is. And the Adventist
goes, "Well, you know, we preach that,
too."
And a bunch of other stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
But they don't want to say that. But
they they that's their out. That's their
card they throw down saying, "Well, we
preach that too,
right?" But what's the Apostle Paul say?
No, there is a gospel message. It's not
three paragraphs of Adventist text, the
message you get from angels, there's a
message and it's 1 Corinthians 15 1-4.
and Adventists. What God, the Lord Jesus
Christ gave to John the Apostle in the
Revelation. It's Jesus Christ revelation
by the way, Revelation 1. The revelation
of Jesus Christ to John the Apostle, the
everlasting gospel that is mentioned in
Revelation 14 is not a different gospel
than what Paul mentions in Galatians 1.
It can't be. Jesus Christ is the only
one that revealed this gospel. Paul goes
to great lengths, James, in the rest of
Galatians or Galatia the rest of chapter
1 to explain how it was verified by the
apostles that Jesus Christ did appear to
to Paul because he explains he went to
wherever he went to and he was blinded
remember on his Damascus road experience
and when he met up with the apostles he
says he hadn't seen them in like two
weeks or something or it was like a two
week span between when that happened and
when he saw the apostles he reiterated
to them what the Lord Jesus gave to him
and they said, "You had to have gotten
this by the Lord Jesus Christ because we
haven't seen you, and we're the only
ones that you could have gotten this
from." So Paul says in Galatians 1,
again, a different gospel is a cursed.
It can't be different in Revelation 14
that this, well, the everlasting gospel
is a malleable sort of No, no, no, no,
no, no. There's one gospel. There's one
gospel message. Continue what you were
saying. Yeah. No. And and to your point,
I've had 7th Day Adventist will uh want
to challenge me and say, "Well, in
Revelation 14, what is the everlasting
gospel?" And I said, "Well, you know, in
biblical interpretation, we use the
clearer scriptures to interpretate th
interpret those that are unclear." And
you're right. And the the phrase
everlasting gospel is not defined for us
there. Okay. Well, then what is the
gospel and where is it defined? Well,
brother, we just we just read re or
Romans 4 and he that's what I was
getting at with him hearkening back to
David who had the same understanding.
He had the same understanding, folks.
The gospel is not unique to, oh, it's
just some modernday thing like only we
have it now. No, folks, this is getting
now into covenant theology and we're not
going to go that route down that
tonight. But it's always been the same
gospel. That's why it's everlasting.
We're all saved the same way. You're not
going to get into eternity and some
people were there because of one reason
and some other people were there for a
different reason and no, we're all there
for the same reason and it's the same
gospel message. That's why it's
everlasting. It the whole problem
between with their understanding of
Revelation is they're importing this
great controversy theme over the book of
Revelation and ising it into the text
and not understanding what's really
being said. But um continue if you had
something else to say on there. Sorry,
I'm I'm not trying to interrupt you.
just things that are coming to my mind.
Yeah. And uh
this is of utmost importance. Yes.
Because the consequences here are are
severe. I mean, I say to Adventists all
the time, why do you want to preach a
gospel which the Bible curses twice?
Why do you want to do that? Because
well, that's what you're doing.
And and and that's why I often say and
Adventists will say, "Why why do you
call us non-Christians?" Well, here's
one reason. You have a different gospel.
And and this is not a minor issue. This
is not like, "Are you a young earth
creationist or an old earth creationist?
Do you stand up when you sing or do you
sit down when you sing worship songs?"
No. This is a message which is given to
us from the word of God that says if you
do something different, you're cursed.
Yep. And you got the curses of God on
you. So this is serious. So any religion
like the Jehovah Witness gospel, they
have the gospel of 1914. Christ came
invisibly in 1914 to rule in the
heavenlies. That's their gospel message.
Watchtower magazine 1981, they got a
different gospel. And you know what? So
do you 7th Day Adventists, you have the
same cursed message. And if you are
concerned with biblical truth, then you
will get out of this religion. You will
say, "I do not want to be in a religion
which preaches a cursed message." Then
it's time to go. And if you don't go,
then all I all I got to say to you is
you are just willfully in rebellion and
holding on to your allegiance to the SDA
church for some reason, which you know,
we don't know, but you are. But I just
want to throw that on the table that
you're preaching a cursed gospel and
your retention of that is just a
reflection on you at this point. Yep.
So, I'm going to read another quote
here. This is from the inspired pen, aka
Ellen White. This is from Review and
Herald, July 7, 1891, paragraph 11. It
says, quote, "The three messages for
this time, again, for this time, are of
most solemn import, and it is of the
greatest consequence to those who hear
whether or not they act upon the light
given." So, this is a foundational thing
for a specific time and there's great
consequences for rejecting it. I'm going
to read another quote here. It's a
little long, but it's also from the
Review and Herald, July 7, 1891,
paragraphs 13- 15 says, quote, "Then
brethren, use wisely the precious light
that God has given." Again, the light
that God is giving, that's through Ellen
White, presenting it to the people in
the meekness and gentleness of Christ.
meet the prejudice of the people with an
invitation such as Philip gave
Nathaniel. Come and see. Say, if Seventh
Day Adventists have the truth and can
prove it so from the oracles of God, you
do not wish to be found fighting against
God.
We are to be bodies of light proclaiming
Christ and his love to the people and
presenting all of our doctrines in their
true relation to this important theme. I
don't want to stop and sidetrack here. I
just want to comment and say with how
much you've engaged with them, how much
are they just presenting their
doctrines. They're just just coming
coming through crystal clear what they
believe. She continues, "We must expect
to meet opposition and unbelief.
The truth has always had to meet these
elements."
In the days of Christ, the scribes and
Pharisees were filled with opposition to
his work. She uses this analogy a lot
about the the Jewish leaders of the past
coming up against Christ is the same
analogy to the religious leaders of the
day coming up against Ellen White's
message.
The the truth has always had to meet
these elements. In the days of Christ,
the scribes and Pharisees were filled
with opposition to his work. When it was
declared that God so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son that
whosoever believeth in him should not
perish but have everlasting life, they
were as full of criticism and prejudice
as this statement as are the people
today when they hear the doctrines held
by the seventh day Adventist. We shall
have to meet people as full of hatred to
our work as were the priests and rulers
in the days of Christ's work. It is our
duty, however, to diffuse light in every
direction and lay out in clear lines
what the sinner must do in order to
obtain eternal life. Close quote. So,
this was from a manuscript, folks. You
can read it yourself talking or it's
reviewing herald rather talking about
their duty. Well, it's actually from
both. It's from a manuscript and that's
obviously how her writings worked. A lot
of times stuff from the manuscripts was
ported over into other areas whether
it's compilation books or papers etc. Um
where she's literally talking about
their duty to herald what they think the
three angels messages of revelation 14
is. That's what the context of this
whole thing was is that they need to be
bold in taking this three angels message
to the world. She says SDAs have the
truth and going against it is fighting
against God.
It's salvific and eternal life hinges on
it.
She continues, "Letters and manuscripts
volume 6 1889 through 90 uh paragraph
33."
She says, "Quote, time is short. The
first, second, and third angel's
messages are the messages to be given to
the world. We hear not literally the
voice of the three angels, but these
angels in Revelation represent a people
who will be upon the earth and give
these messages. Who is that, James?
Well, that's the seventh day adventist
church. Correct. She continues the signs
of the or she says uh in the signs of
the times January 25, 1910. This is 5
years before her death. Paragraph 5.
These three angels represent the people
who accept the light of God's messages
and go forth as his agents to sound the
warning throughout the length and
breadth of the earth. Close quote.
So now folks, we're going to get into
each of the angels, what each of these
angels messages are. As you've clearly
seen, this is a foundational aspect to
their church. This is their gospel
message. This is what the 7th Adventist
Church believes that they were specially
tasked for by God. That's the language
that they use in those circles. They
have a special mission from God revealed
to them to take not just to the lost
world but to the Christian world.
The first angel's message. James, do you
know what the first angel's message is?
Or what all does it entail? Yeah. Yeah.
And that can even depend on the source
you read. But generally speaking, uh the
the hour of his judgment has arrived.
That's a pretty consistent theme of that
first angel's message. Another one that
I see associated with it is that the
call to the Sabbath has been issued a
call the attention to um you know
fighting the evils of evolution also.
But I see generally speaking though I I
want to say it's the hour the big thing
big piece I think the hour of his
judgment has come and depending on the
source you read it'll start defining
what they mean by judgment well which is
1844 this really the first angel message
is the kickoff of the investigative
judgment um and which and first angel
you know I mean that's that first
element of the gospel so the gospel is
related to the investigative judgment
it's funny you say that because maybe
you have the gift of prophecy because
this is from the great controversy, one
of the big three,
page 457. The online code is GC457.1
for those that want to check that out.
It says, quote, "The preaching of a
definite time for the judgment, as you
just mentioned, in the giving of the
first message was ordered by God.
the computation of the prophetic periods
of which that message was based, placing
the close of the 2300 days in the autumn
of 1844. For those that don't know,
that's Daniel 8:14.
It stands without impeachment. The
repeated efforts to find new dates for
the beginning of the close of the
prophetic periods and the unound
reasoning necessary to sustain these
positions not only leads minds away from
the present truth, but throw contempt
upon all efforts to explain the
prophecies. So the false date setting,
James, um was ordained by God, but only
that one time. You're not don't do any
date setting anymore. 1844 was the only
valid one. Um so yeah, that first
angel's message entails a number of
things depending on what source you're
quoting, but it's talking about
repenting of Darwinism, understanding
when it mentions that worship the
creator of heaven and earth. It's
talking about if you believe evolution,
you're not worshiping the one true God,
which we're not getting into all that
tonight, but that's essentially a a
tertiary part of it. But the primary
thing is the beginning of the
investigative judgment, which started in
1844. We're going to get into that in a
little bit. The second angel's message.
Oh, yeah. What is this? What is the
second angel's message, James? And then
I'm going to have another quote um
coming from the the source. All right.
That's simply stated, come out of
Babylon.
And by that, what they mean are all
apostate religious organizations.
And you're in these apostate religious
organizations because your church has is
in allegiance with the beast, with
Catholicism who changed the Sabbath, and
you are worshiping on the Sabbath
because of this allegiance. So, it's
time to come on Sunday. I'm sorry. On
Sunday. So, it's time to come out of
your Sunday churches which have been
persuaded by the beast to do that. Come
out of Babylon and and come to the
Sabbath. The remnant. Yeah. Yeah. The
remnant. So, she says, quote, now get
this. This is from the Spirit of
Prophecy,
volume 4, page 232.
The online code is 4SP space 232.1.
quote, "When the churches spurn the
council of God by rejecting the advent
message." So, she's speaking here about
the churches of their day that rejected
their fanaticism, their date setting,
1844, all of that stuff.
When they spurned the council of God by
rejecting the Advent message, the Lord
rejected them.
The first angel was followed by a second
proclaiming Babylon is fallen is fallen
that great city because she made all
nations drink of the wine of the wrath
of her fornication. That's Revelation
14:8.
This message was understood by
Adventists
to be an announcement of the moral fall
of the churches in consequence of their
rejection of the first message. End
quote.
because people rejected the fanaticism
of 1844 and the investigative judgment,
the pivot, which we're not, again, we're
not getting into all that tonight, but
the pivot from what Miller essentially
said about the second coming, Miller
never believed the investigative
judgment. A lot of these people never
believed they went back to their other
movements or whatever. So when they
rejected all of that, that whole chain,
Miller's date setting, which was then
the investigative judgment was birthed
out of due to the crazy Miller chart and
all that stuff, them refusing to accept
they were wrong. God rejected them.
The second angel's message is to warn of
the apostasy of churches who rejected
the message. She says here, this is how
she defines it. Quote, little bit of a
long quote. Same book, Spirit of
Prophecy, Volume 4, page 232.
Quote, "The term Babylon is is derived
from Babel and signifies confusion and
is applied in scripture to the various
forms of false or apostate religion. But
the message announcing the fall of
Babylon must apply to some serious body
that was one serious body that was once
pure and has become corrupt. It can't be
the Roman church which is here meant for
that church has been in a fallen
condition for many centuries. But how
appropriate the figure as applied to the
Protestant churches
all professing to derive their doctrines
from the Bible yet divided in almost
innumerable sex. I'm going to refrain
from making my comments about the
Adventists and how that's the pot
calling the kettle black.
The unity for which Christ prayed does
not exist.
Instead of one Lord, one faith, one
baptism, there are numberless conflicts
or conflicting creeds and theories.
Religious faith appears so confused and
dis uh discordant that the world know
not what they uh what to believe as
truth. God is not in all this. It is the
work of man, the work of Satan.
Close quote.
That's the second angel.
Any thoughts, James? Another thought on
the second angel message, which is what
I I get all the time when I meet
Adventists. They want to greet me and
say, "Hey, brother,
like brother in Christ."
And of course, I always correct them and
say, "I'm sorry, we're not brothers in
Christ because you're not Christian. You
got a false Jesus, false gospel." But
along the line of the second angel,
what's the second angel's message? Come
out of Babylon. It's the false apostate
churches.
Any Adventist that calls anybody outside
Adventism
brother or tries to recognize them as
Christians, you're really rejecting your
own doctrine. Your own doctrine says
it's a closed system in terms of
Adventism and anything outside our walls
is apostate religion.
But yet you like to call other people
brothers or say, "Yeah, there's, you
know, other God has his people in other
church." Not in Adventism. No, he
doesn't. And then the second angel is
really clear. Everything is aposticized
except for the remnant. And by the way,
you just read at the end of your quote
about a unity in the Adventist church.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Unity. You know
what? The first thing that came to my
mind was unity because I run across
these Adventists all the time. I I
they're the anti-terrinitarian 7th day
Adventist. Yeah. Who this big strain now
I I I see it growing. Um I I I also call
them historic Adventist or pioneer
Adventist would be another good term.
Yep. Who want to go back to the times of
Loftboro and James White and shoot some
of them want to go back to Smith. Uriah
Smith. Yeah. Pre-188
Uriah. Yes. Yes. Yes. Jesus was a
created being. That's right. And u So
yeah, the unity, right? I mean I mean I
the seventh day Adventist church is
fracturing crazy Walter Vice out there
of some of his nonsense that he spews
and you know and on and on and on we
could go. He's dangerous man. Unity. Oh
yeah. That that guy is dangerous. Oh
yeah. So yeah. Yeah. When you said when
you were talking about unity I'm
thinking right. What? What unity? Just
car the comments of both you and I's
YouTube channels and you're gonna
clearly see Yeah. They're really united.
Oh yeah. really really united. So, okay.
So, that's the second message. So,
here's now the third angel's message.
And there's actually a bonus for you
folks. It's kind of like the um call now
and receive, you know, we actually have
a bonus for you. There's actually a
fourth angel's message. So, third
angel's message. Quote, this is from
manuscripts or manuscript of life
sketches, page 166.
Quote, I was shown that the third angel
proclaiming the commandments of God and
the faith of Jesus represents the people
who received this message and raise the
voice of warning to the world to keep
the commandments of God and his law as
the apple of the eye and that in
response to this warning, many would
embrace
Christ. No, the Sabbath of the Lord.
Close quote.
So speaking back to what you said
earlier about the focus on
she thankfully accepted the Sabbath 30
years ago in the obituary there it is
that's the emphasis accepted the Sabbath
because in their minds that means that
you have um come to a fullness of the
truth you have the seal now etc. So part
of the third third angel's message is
seventh day Sabbathke keeping.
Another quote again about the third
angel's message from one of the big
three the great controversy page 457.
Quote the history of ancient Israel is a
striking illustration of the past
experience of the Adventist body. God
led his people in the advent movement
even as he led the children of Israel in
Egypt. In the great disappointment,
that's 1844,
their faith was tested, as was that of
the Hebrews at the Red Sea.
Had they still trusted to the guiding
hand that had been with them in their
past experience, they would have seen
the salvation of God.
If all who had labored unitedly in in
the work of 1844 had received the third
angel's message and proclaimed it in the
power of the Holy Spirit, the Lord would
have wrought mightily with their
efforts. A flood of light would have
been shed upon the world. Years ago, the
inhabitants of earth would have been
warned, the closing work completed, and
Christ would have come for the
redemption of his people. Close quote.
So, the great disappointment was a faith
test.
those who left their movement, walked
away from salvation, and had the SDAs
been proclaiming this third angel's
message more powerfully or people, you
know, previously, Christ would have
returned by now. And if you watch, which
I know that you have on your your
channel because I've seen the videos
about this. If you watch things like the
GC, the general conference session where
people like Ted Wilson, the president of
the worldwide 7th Day Adventist Church,
give their speech, especially the one, I
think it's from 2015, uh, San Antonio, I
think it was.
Every one of these, the GC president is
lambasting them. He's giving them a scay
thing. A lot of times it's passively.
It's not as direct, but he's saying if
we were doing our duty, Christ would be
back by now. He's waiting on the advent
body to be doing and proclaiming this
message effectively enough that Christ
then returns.
But then it continues, James,
it doesn't include just that. This is
from testimonies for the church. Another
one of the big ones volume 4 page 486
says quote the health reform I was shown
is a part of the third angel's message
and is just as closely connected with it
as are the arm in hand with the body. So
now we attach another thing that wasn't
even mentioned in the uh the review and
herald article. Now we have another
thing that's added into the foundational
fundamental things. Remember these three
angels are their gospel. Their message
of health reform is a part of the third
angel's message and it's attached to
that just as much as the arm is to the
body.
I saw that we as a people must make an
advanced move in this great work.
Ministers and people must act in
concert. God's people are not prepared
for the loud cry of the third angel.
They have a work to do for themselves
which they should not leave for God to
do for them. He has left this work to
them to do. Close quote. So their
message of health reform is also a part
of the third angel's message.
Thoughts on that, brother? Yeah, you're
you're absolutely right. So you read
something from the testimonies and it's
got the the health message in it. Well,
this book here from 2018
says exactly the same thing. And tell
tell the audience what that is. What
book are you holding? Uh, the
disciplehip handbook. And by the way,
you should hold this carefully because
if you read the preface, it says this
book was inspired by the Holy Spirit.
Yeah, I'm serious. Read the preface.
It's what it says. So, I've got
something here from from God in my hand.
So, hold it carefully. I I put it in a
box at night and cover it up out of
respect. Right. So, uh, yeah. I mean,
this book here written in 2018 says
exactly the same thing that you just
quoted from Ellen White. So, the message
is consistent. And as you're reading
this, I'm thinking again, and I want to
say to the Adventist audience, we just
went over the three angels messages from
your sources.
First angel, judgment is coming, right?
1844,
keep the Sabbath. Second angel, get out
of the apostate Babylon Sundayeping
churches. Third angel's message, keep
the commandments. And if you're
worshiping on Sunday when Jesus comes
back and you know you should be
worshiping on Saturday, you're gonna get
the mark of the beast and the health
message. And the health message.
Now, you read the gospel earlier to us.
First Corinthians, none of that was in
there. 15 1-4.
Nope.
This
gospel, huh? You know what I say to
that?
Whoops. Yeah.
[Music]
I mean, there it is.
You just went over the three angels
messages. You read 1 Corinthians 15 1-4.
And if you're an Advent Dennis and you
were listening to Miles,
there's a difference.
And again, now you ought to be
concerned. Read Galatians chapter 1:es
6-9. Because you preach to three angels
messages, you're cursed. So yeah.
Anyway, as you're reading it, I'm just
thinking, we just read 1 Corinthians 15.
I certainly hope they realize that
nothing you just read's in 1 Corinthians
15. Well, and things that she was just
saying in there, these are things that
you have to ascribe to and adhere to to
be seen as reconciled to God. Yeah. In
order to be justified, it runs deep in
this movement. But here's the bonus. out
James the fourth angel which is often
times left off but it's the final
angel's message which is really
reiterating the second some of the
second angel's message this is quote
from letters and manuscripts volume 15
says quote read revelation 18 which
gives the outcome of all those who have
refused loyalty to God and his
commandments
the whole earth is to be lighted with
the glory of the of that other angel who
follows the third angel and whose
message unites with his.
Here is the last call to mystic Babylon,
the churches that have been corrupt. I
just saw a short on YouTube from the 7th
Avenist Church's official YouTube page
literally laying out this whole thing.
Basically saying that like this is the
final call. We're giving the final
herald here in this fourth angel's
message in these religious bodies is to
be heard the last call. The warning,
Babylon the great is fallen, is fallen,
and has become the habitation of devils
and the hold of every foul spirit and a
cage of every unclean and hateful bird.
Close quote. So, it's a final warning to
come out of apostate Protestantism. So
their gospel entails the investigative
judgment, essentially young earth
creationism, the preaching against
Darwinism and all that, the seventh day
Sabbath, the SDA health reform message,
and leaving what they call apostate
Protestant churches.
None of which was revealed by Jesus
Christ to the apostles handed down to
the saints. None of it. They admitted it
themselves, did they not? And not only
did they say in the magazine that you
quoted, we cannot preach the gospel that
Paul preached.
Correct. Again, admission you cannot
preach 1 Corinthians 15, which is the
only gospel to preach and preach
anything else is cursed. I have a quote
here on my screen from 1932, which says
in essence, nobody before 1844 ever
preached this message. Yeah. Well, no
kidding.
You know, so how can it be a gospel
message if no one before 1844 ever
preached it? And how does that make it
everlasting?
Yeah, exactly. I like, like I said, I
turn it over and it says made in 1844.
Yeah, that's the gospel message.
Totally.
So, let's look at what she says here
about how one is now reconciled to God.
So, there you have that gospel message.
Now, let's contrast this with what
scripture says in Romans 5 about how one
is reconciled to God. You can even go to
2 Corinthians 5 for those that are
curious. The ministry of reconciliation.
This is from testimonies for the church
volume 4 page 294.
Quote, "Man who has defaced the image of
God in his soul by a corrupt life cannot
by mere human effort affect a radical
change in himself. He must accept the
provisions of the gospel." Well, we just
heard what that was, did we not? Was
that the gospel message?
Yeah. Not the truth. He must be he must
be reconciled to God through obedience
to his law and faith in Jesus Christ. Is
that what Romans 5 said, Jim? No.
His life from then forth must be
governed by a new principle. I would
agree. When a person is regenerated,
they have new desires and stuff. Now,
the issue is they're not reconciled to
God by their faith and the law. This is
an addition now.
Through repentance, faith, and good
works, he may perfect a righteous
character and claim through the merits
of Christ the privileges of the sons of
God. Close quote.
So notice, she says, must one accept the
provision, one must accept the
provisions of the gospel. We just heard
what that what that is defined as. And
in contrast to Romans 5 saying we're
reconciled by faith in the person and
work of Christ on the cross alone
because nothing else is mentioned.
That's why it's alone. Even if the word
alone is not mentioned, we're saying
that because nothing else is mentioned.
Paul says he believed. It was credited
to him as righteousness. He was seen as
holy, righteous in Christ.
The works, everything else came after
that. It didn't retain that. Abraham did
that because he was seen as righteous.
But Ellen says it's our faith and
obedience to the law. Again, showcasing
their what I said earlier, their lack of
a law gospel distinction. So, that's how
they believe one is reconciled to God.
What do they believe about the
atonement, Jim?
Um, yeah, this was a doctrine that
surprised me when I first started
studying Adventism. I just didn't see it
coming. I didn't expect it. Um, I like
the quote from Uriah Smith and for
whatever an Adventist has to say about
Uriah Smith and all his baggage, the
same kind of quotes come from Ellen
White and a variety of other leaders.
But Uriah Smith is really clear in his
um book called Looking Unto Jesus 1898.
And I got an original edition in my
library and Uriah Smith said this.
Christ did not make atonement when he
shed blood uh his blood upon the cross.
Let this fact be fixed forever in your
mind. I want to say that again. Christ
did not make atonement when he shed his
blood upon the cross. Let this fact be
fixed forever in your mind. That's Uriah
Smith in 1898. Again, whatever baggage
you want to say, Uriah Smith came to the
table with, and I granted he did, but
Ellen White said the same kind of
things. Catrell said the same kind of
things. And I've got dozens of quotes on
this same line. They deny the atonement
of Christ. What happened on the cross?
I'm not exactly sure in Adventism
because I got a I got a few different
answers, but I I essentially just want
to say nothing because sins are not
forgiven on the cross. It's just the
atoning sacrifice. Yeah. So Christians
out there, you need to understand when
they talk about the cross of Christ,
they're not talking about a completed
atonement. They are talking about the
atonement essentially. Well, actually,
if you go through their whole sanctuary,
sotiology, Jim, I don't know how much
you've done of this, the seven steps of
the sanctuary, and that the cross of
Christ is only one of the steps in this
whole chain of this pre-earth origin
story. We're not getting into all that
tonight. I'm actually going to be doing
a series on all of these different steps
and walking through all this so people
can understand what they're talking
about. The cross of Christ was only the
atoning sacrifice. Now, I want to read a
quote to you. This is in multiple
places. You've talked about this on your
channel before, but folks, if you
haven't heard this before, buckle up.
This is from Christ in His Sanctuary,
which is a compilation book. Ellen
White, of course, page 56, as well as
Patriarchs and Prophets, another one of
the that's one of the big three, page
357. Quote, "The blood of Christ, while
it was to release the repentant sinner
from the condemnation of the law, was
not to cancel the sin.
It would stand the sin on record in the
sanctuary until the final atonement."
So in the type speaking about Leviticus
16, the blood of the sin offering
removed the sin from the penitent, but
it rested in the sanctuary until the day
of atonement. Close quote.
They don't believe the atonement is
finished. Folks, you have to understand
this. They think the final atonement is
taking place in heaven. Essentially
currently Christ is currently up there
in the sanctuary doing this work of the
investigative judgment that was part of
the three angels gospel. So Jim,
what is the investigative judgment
aspect of their atonement model? I'm
going to read a number of quotes here.
We're not going to go through all of
them because there's a lot and I don't
want to take up the rest of our time. We
have to get into Jesus as well. Yeah.
Yeah. But we have to talk about this
investigative judgment. Yeah. Because
this gets into how a person is
reconciled. It gets into the again the
gospel message. This is a core
component. And folks, pay attention
here, Jim. What is the investigative
judgment aspect of their atonement
model? So, it is a fake Christ. I'm
going to say it's a Christ who's dressed
as a Levitical priest. They call him a
high priest. Um, and then and you have
and and and I have pictures and one from
as recent as 2014 of Christ dressed in
Levitical priest garb. I've got a whole
series of pictures collected. So when
they say high priest, by the way, high
priest is a title
um of of a priesthood. It's high priest
is not a it's not a description of a
priesthood. I mean you can be a high
wiccan priest or a high priest in
Levitical priesthood. I mean vastly
different. So Adventist when they say
high priest, they really mean high
levitical priest. Yep. And and and
that's evidenced by the pictures. So you
got Christ dressed in Levitical priest
garb, which means now he's of the tribe
of Levi. That's the first problem. No,
he's not. He's of the tribe of Judah.
He's not of the Levitical priest. And
oh, by the way, when he's after the
order of MelkiseDc, that's right. And
the thing that's interesting about that
Genesis 14 and Hebrews 6 is the
Malchisedcian priesthood. Unlike again
they fail to see the compare and
contrast in Hebrews. They're looking for
all this similarity to go back to Sinai
and back to the Levitical priesthood.
Mkisedc was a priest king. This is an
important factor because Jesus Christ is
a priest king. The Levitical priest was
not a priest king. Jesus is a priest
king. Not a Levitical priest wearing
Levitical priesthood garb doing the
analogous work of the Levitical priest
but only in heaven. Continue. Yeah. And
you're right. As you're talking, I was
thinking about that. And if you look at
all the kings in the Old Testament. Yep.
None. None of them were priest kings.
No, there were kings and there were
priests.
None of them were kings. Exactly.
Exactly. That's why Christ is unique in
that he's prophet, priest, and king.
That's right. But continue. So in
Leviticus 16, the day of atonement in
this whole scenario, investigative
judgment, the le the Levitical priests
had to first atone for their sins. Yeah.
Before they atoned for the sins of
Israel. So Adventists like to say, well
uh the sanctuary is just a uh just a
copy of the basically the day of
atonement. And I would say, well then
you make Jesus a sinner because you make
him a Levitical priest and Levitical
priest had to atone for their sins. And
by the way, he's not a Levitical priest.
He's of the order of Melzdc, right?
Hebrews 7. So you have this Levitical
priest 1844 Jesus
examining the sins only of believers
in heaven. And and Ellen White in the
Great Controversy tells us one of three
things are going to happen at this
point. your sins are are going to be
what she say they're going to be
forgiven or they're or or and and
can't find my quote or they're they're
going to you're going to you're sins are
going to be forgiven or they're not
going to be forgiven or you're going to
be blotted out of the lamb's book of
life. Period. Yeah. Well, that's the
point in Adventist theology where sins
are forgiven. It's by this Levitical
priest Christ who's examining these
books in heaven pronouncing the final
judgment on believers. So again, what
happened on the cross in Adventism? The
answer is nothing because it all happens
in this sanctuary of Christ. Yeah.
Christ basically the the cross was just
about um making the way of salvation
possible by Jesus paying the penalty
because they don't believe Adam and Eve
when God said the day that you eat of
it, you'll die. They don't believe that.
They believe the process of death began
because this gets in and out of their
physicalism. Adam and Eve didn't die
spiritually. So, they make God a liar
there, too. That God said, "In the day
that you eat of it, you will surely
die." And they did, but it wasn't
physically, it was spiritually. But, you
nailed it there. That um the the cross
of Christ is essentially the doorway to
make salvation a possibility to pay the
penalty for sin, which is death, but the
atonement itself would take place in a
sanctuary in heaven. So, I'm going to
read here. This is a quote from Ellen
White again, Evangelism, page 221. She
says, quote, "The correct understanding
of the ministration in the heavenly
sanctuary is the foundation of our
faith."
Is this a serious topic, folks? The
foundation of your faith. She says,
"Those who reject this doctrine, their
prayers are an abomination to God." This
is quote, "Spiritual gifts, volume one,
page 189.
I saw that since Jesus had left the holy
place in the heavenly sanctuary and had
entered within the second veil, that's
what happened supposedly in 1844,
the churches were left as were the Jews.
Again, with this analogy,
and they have been filling up with every
unclean and hateful bird. I saw great
iniquity and vileeness in the churches,
yet they profess to be Christians. their
profession, their prayers, and their
exhortations are an abomination in the
sight of God. Close quote.
Don't give me this nonsense. Adventists,
I'm just I get and and you've probably
gotten to this too, James. Like, I'm to
the point with with some of them. You
have to understand, folks, when you've
been doing this with investing a lot of
time and effort and energy and and all
this and been doing it for a long time,
you start to hear all the same responses
over and over. And it's hard to I
understand we need to exercise patience
and those sorts of things, but it
becomes hard to exercise patience when
you guys try to say, "It's all good,
brother."
No. No. Own up to what your church
actually believes. We're here being
honest tonight. You guys are not
Christians. If you affirm what's being
said tonight, you affirm official 7th
Adventist teaching, you're not a
Christian. You need to repent. You're in
danger. You're in serious danger. I know
you guys don't believe hell is eternal,
that separation from God, that you have
an immaterial aspect to your being.
You're wrong. This is a dire warning
tonight. If you believe this stuff
tonight, you are in grave danger. And if
you're an honest Seventh Day Adventist,
you're going to own the things that are
said here and be upfront and say the
same thing about us. You guys are in
danger. you need to repent. So you guys
need to be honest about this stuff. She
says in this quote, "No sins are blotted
out before the second coming of Christ."
This is from Christ in his sanctuary.
The compilation book page 180 says,
quote, "The work of investigative
judgment and the blotting out of sins is
to be accomplished before or sorry,
sorry, sorry. I said earlier that no
sins are blotted out. It's that like you
said at the cross, no sins were blotted
out. The work of investigative judgment
and the blotting out of sins is to be
accomplished before the second advent of
the Lord. Since the dead are to be
judged out of the things written in the
books, it is impossible that the sins of
men should be blotted out until after
the judgment at which their cases are to
be investigated. So your sins aren't
blotted out now. That includes you
Adventists. So when you say that you
have security and that you know that
you're not going to be condemned and all
these things, no, you don't know that.
You can't say that consistently. You
don't know if you've passed this
judgment or not. We're going to get into
the standard of what passing it is here
in a moment, but you don't know when
your name is going to come up. You don't
know that you've passed this judgment,
and you don't know that your sins aren't
still standing against you. She
continues, "But the Apostle Peter
distinctly states that the sins of
believers will be blotted out." And then
she quotes Acts three here, "When the
times of refreshing shall come from the
presence of the Lord, and he shall send
Jesus Christ."
So that hasn't happened yet. what was
happening there in acts 1-4 essentially
that hasn't hap that was Peter wasn't
prophesying you know talking about about
Joel saying it's happening now no that's
going to be some future thing which that
gets into their whole the latter reign
and the fall of the spirit
when the investigative judgment closes
Christ will come and his reward will be
with him to give to every man as his
work shall be close quote
what are your thoughts on that James no
sins are blotted out until up in heaven
Christ is going to begin some sort of
atoning work there which is the next
phase of atonement. So you just said
without saying the word probation
because that's this intermediary
position that all 7-day adventists are
in. You are in probation. You are not
forgiven because like Miles said, you
don't know when your so-called
investigation happened. As a Christian,
I know the moment that I believed my
sins are forgiven. Yeah. Yeah, cuz we
were judged at the cross. I'm right. I
am not in probation
sitting, you know, in angst. And I've
heard many stories from many former 7th
day Adventists who have told me the same
story. Adventists that don't even know
formers that don't even know each other,
keep telling me the same thing. They lay
in bed at night because they know they
have to confess every single sin. And
they wonder, did I confess every single
sin today? cuz if I forgot and I haven't
been judged yet in the investigation, I
will not pass.
And so this whole investigative judgment
just builds fear into you have no
eternal security as a seventh day
adventist. And you I mean of course we
all a lot of us in here already know
this. Ellen White taught don't you ever
say you're saved, right? Christ object
lessons. Yeah. And and and so you're
right. I mean it leaves the Adventist in
a horrible place. Now, besides that,
it's completely unbiblical.
As we've already gone over tonight
several times, you are justified when
you place your faith in Christ like
Abraham did, like the Apostle Paul did,
David did,
all of all of the saints of old did. So,
you mentioned probation there. That's
perfect segue into this next quote. So
this investigative judgment period, if
you understand the history between the
shut door and all this stuff and the new
door opening in the most holy place, it
was to extend the period of probation.
This term probation, it's funny because
a lot of Adventists like to use this
whole like the word trinity is not found
in the Bible. Well, you're using the
word Bible and that's not found in the
Bible. But you guys also, if you just do
a quick word search on the Ellen White
Library, you're going to get like 1500
hits on the term probation. That's never
mentioned in the Bible. It's mentioned
in the Book of Mormon, but it's not
mentioned in the Bible. So, this quote,
she talks about man's on a probationary
period to prove his loyalty to God,
which is part of what this investigation
is about. So, this is from Letters and
Manuscripts volume 18, 1903, paragraphs
1 and two. It says, quote, "Man sinned,
the death is or and death is penalty of
sin." So, see that's again, Jesus paid
the penalty for sin, which is death.
That's what the cross was really about.
Christ bore the penalty which is death
and secured for man a period of
probation. So see it made salvation a
possibility extending the the period of
probation here. That's what the cross of
Christ was essentially about there.
Christ paid the penalty for which is
death. Extended the period of probation.
That's what the cross of Christ was
about. In this time of probation we are
now living. We have been given an
opportunity to prove our loyalty to him
who gave his only begotten son that we
should not perish but have everlasting
life. God is testing us. Is that the
gospel James that you can be put on a
period where God is now testing you? No.
No. Jesus says in all throughout the
gospel of John, Jesus knows his sheep.
They hear his voice and they listen.
Jesus knows his people.
But in this, God is testing people.
He's extending a period of time where
they can demonstrate that they're really
sincere and loyal. He entrusts us with
talents. This is getting into their idea
now of what spiritual gifts are, which
is an interesting topic for another
time. To see whether we will be
thoroughly unselfish in the use we make
of them. physical, mental, and spiritual
gifts are placed in our possession, and
on the use that we make of these gifts
depends our eternal destiny. Close
quote.
Here she says, "A single sin on your
record in this judgment will have your
name blotted out of the book of life."
So, this is getting at what you were
saying earlier. I was that way as a kid.
I would sit up in bed saying, "God, if
there's any sins I've forgotten, please
forgive me of them." because and I would
think I'm I'm kind of a unique person I
think in this regard that I'm a a pretty
introspective and like deep thinker and
so I was even that way as a kid and I
remember thinking to myself what if I
die in my sleep what if I just don't
wake up and there's one that I forgotten
so I would sit there so you're exactly
right that is the teaching
she says quote this is from Christ in
his sanctuary page 177
as the books of record are opened in the
judgment the lives of all who have
believed on Jesus, come in review before
God. So, this is only for professed
believers. She says elsewhere in the
same work and other places, it's all the
way back to Adam. Anyone who's professed
faith from the beginning of the human
race down to the present day,
beginning with those who first lived
upon the earth, our advocate presents
the cases of each successive generation
and closes with the living. Every name
is mentioned, every case closely
investigated. Names are accepted, names
are rejected. When any have sins
remaining upon the books of record,
unrepentant, unrepented of or forgotten,
their names will be blotted out of the
book of life, and the record of their
good deeds will be erased from the book
of God's remembrance." Close quote. She
continues in on that same thing, same
book, Christ in his sanctuary, page 182.
Five pages later,
Christ in his sanctuary, page 182. At
the time appointed for the judgment, the
close of the 2300 days in 1844 began the
work of investigation and blotting out
of sins. All who have ever taken upon
themselves the name of Christ must pass
its its searching scrutiny. Both the
living and the dead are to be judged out
of the things written in the books
according to their works. Close quote.
She even continues in this same book,
Christ in his sanctuary, page 177.
quote, "All who have truly repented of
sin and by faith claim the blood of
Christ as their here's that phrase
atoning sacrifice
have had pardon entered against their
names in the books of heaven as they
have become partakers of the righteous
righteousness of Christ and their
characters are found to be in harmony
with the law of God.
Their sins will be blotted out and they
themselves will be accounted worthy of
eternal life." Close quote. So they love
to tell me all the time, James, "No, no,
no. We believe in the righteousness of
Christ. We believe in the imputed
righteousness of Christ, just like you
guys do." No, you don't. No, you don't.
You believe just like she said earlier,
faith, repentance, and and obedience to
the law, good works. Those are the
things that reconcile you in order to
pass this investigation. the
righteousness of Christ that's mentioned
here. It's not like Paul said in in
Philippians 3. I put all of my works of
the law as rubbish because in Christ
that's how I'm seen as righteous. That's
not what's said here. Those who have
accepted Christ's atoning sacrifice have
had pardon entered against their names
in the books of heaven as they have
become partakers of their here it is the
righteousness of righteousness of Christ
which I don't think they define the same
way and their characters are found to be
in harmony with the law of God that's
when their sins will be blotted out. So
when they say atonement folks they do
not mean the cross they mean this whole
long thing. Let me give you one quote
that I that I found recently. So it's
new to me, may not be new to some of
you. If I was to read John 19:30, some
of you are familiar with John 19:30. So
when Jesus had received the sour wine,
he said, "It is finished."
And he bowed his head and gave up his
spirit. I a lot of Christians would say
that's the point at which Jesus paid the
penalty for sins on the cross, right?
When Jesus said, "It is finished."
Right? He paid the penalty for sins. Do
you know that Ellen White rewrote
that verse and that scene?
She did it in early writings.
She says this. Now remember John 19:30
Jesus said, "It is finished on the
cross."
Ellen White has a vision now. And she
says, "I saw angels hurrying to and fro
in heaven." An angel with a writer's ink
horn by his side returned from the earth
and reported to Jesus that his work was
done and the saints were numbered and
sealed. Then I saw Jesus who had been
ministering before the ark containing
the ten commandments throw down the
sensor. He raised his hands and with a
loud voice he said it is done.
That's early writings page 140. That's
Ellen White in a vision rewriting John
19:30
in a putting it in a different setting
and a different time with a completely
different meaning. And and notice too,
brother, they don't have a priest king
who is seated on the throne. They want
to have it both ways. Oh, he's doing
this investigation and he's there
opening the books and all this stuff.
Oh, but he's on the throne. He's still
on the throne. No, no, no, no. The whole
point that the author is making in the
book of Hebrews in this compare and
contrast is showing the Levitical priest
who had to go in once a year and leave
and repeat repeatedly over and over and
over and over. It's the work was never
finished. But Jesus who entered in one
time, that's it. Sat down. The Levitical
priest never sat down because the work
was never finished. Christ is reaping
the benefits of his labors now while all
of his enemies, Hebrews 8:13, are being
made a foottool for him.
So that is just a scratching the surface
on this investigative judgment. One
thing I do want to cover which we didn't
talk about, you can read the chapter of
this. I believe it's Christ in his
sanctuary chapter nine. It's either
eight or nine, the courtroom scene where
you can hear about after this judgment
what happens. those who make it through.
Jesus is only essentially advocating for
those who pass this investigative
judgment. So Jesus isn't mediating for
you before the father the way that
Orthodox Christians understand the
mediation of Christ. That only takes
place after this investigative judgment.
You pass it with uh scrutiny with the
ten commandments being the standard. You
have to have perfect sinlessness that
you've achieved essentially through the
help of the Holy Spirit arriving at a
place where you are sinlessly perfect,
able to stand before Almighty God
without an intercessor.
Then after this courtroom scene where
Satan's there accusing and Jesus is
saying, "I have the evidence that we're
vindicated essentially in saving the
people that we're saving."
Satan is then the scapegoat
that the sins of those found worthy, her
words, those found worthy in the
investigative judgment, those who are
found worthy, their sins are then placed
on Satan.
says, quote, "Christ in his sanctuary,
page 57."
As in the final atonement, the sins of
the truly penitent are to be blotted
from the records of heaven, no more to
be remembered or come into mind, so in
the type they were born away into the
wilderness, forever separated from the
congregation.
Since Satan is the originator of sin,
the direct instigator of all the sins
that caused the death of the son of God,
justice demands that Satan shall suffer
the final punishment. Christ's work for
the redemption of men and the
purification of the universe from sin
will be closed by the removal of sin
from the heavenly sanctuary and the
placing of these sins upon Satan who
will bear the final penalty. So in the
typical service, Leviticus 16, the
yearly round of ministration closed with
the purification of the sanctuary and
the confessing of the sins on the head
of the scapegoat.
Close quote.
This doctrine here, brother, it, you
know, people have commented obviously on
my debate on this topic on my channel
and getting heated with Seventh Day
Adventist Pastor Keith Bowman.
Without getting sidetracked into all of
that, some of that is spurned on by this
damnable heresy.
I don't think a lot of Adventists really
understand here what is being said in
that Satan and Christ accomplished the
atonement, which we're going to go to
the the source now, Jim, so people don't
think that I'm just saying the SDA
church themselves admits in here. We're
going to go to the footnotes, which most
people probably aren't reading through
where they're saying these things.
This is a damnable doctrine in and of
itself. If you think Satan bears your
sins ultimately in the end and expedates
them away from you, which was the
function of the scapegoat,
you believe that Jesus and Satan
accomplish your reconciliation to God.
This is heresy.
This is heresy. The fundamental belief
book, James, on page 357, I'm going to
read a small portion here. um talking
about this specific thing and it's under
the paragraph three which is the
different phases of the judgment. So not
only do you have all this addition of
the atoning sacrifice beginning and then
the atonement in heaven taking place,
you also have the multiple phases of
this judgment that's walking out as
well. And it says atonement by judgment
will therefore bring about a fully
reconciled and harmonious universe. Then
they quote Ephesians 1:10. This is the
objective that the second and final
phase of Christ's priestly ministry in
the heavenly sanctuary will accomplish.
Well, if you continue reading in this
same chapter from page uh it's well,
it's on page 369.
It's part of the footnotes and it's from
footnote number 30. So, it's speaking to
it's page it's footnote number 21 on
page 369.
And it talks about one of the
objections, for example, that I brought
up with Keith in our debate about the
scapegoat.
And it really points out the primary
issue. And this quote that I'm going to
read is from
uh
one of their scholars.
quote,
"If Aazel represents Satan,
how can scripture connect him with the
atonement?" And they're quoting
Leviticus 16:10. This is the verse that
I brought up in my debate with Keith. As
the high priest after having cleansed
the sanctuary placed the sins on Aazel,
we're going to come back to that. Who
was forever removed from God's people.
So Christ after after having cleansed
the heavenly sanctuary will place the
confessed and forgiven sins of his
people on Satan who will then be forever
removed from the saved. How fitting that
the closing act of the drama of God's
dealings with sin should be returning
upon the head of Satan of all the sin
and guilt that issuing from him
originally once brought such tragedy to
the lives of those who uh now freed of
sin by Christ's atoning blood. Thus the
cycle is completed. The drama ended.
This is them quoting Ellen White, by the
way, inserting this in there. Only when
Satan, the instigator of all sin, is
finally removed, can it truly be said
that sin is forever blotted out of God's
universe. In this accommodated sense, we
may understand that the scapegoat has a
part in the atonement.
They just talked about expeation, James,
the taking away of sins. So in that
sense, yeah, Satan can be included in
that with the righteous saved, the
wicked cut off, and Satan no more. Then
not till then will the universe be in a
state of perfect harmony as it
originally was before sin entered. Close
quote. Again, fundamental belief
booknote number 21 from chapter 24,
Christ in the sanctuary, page 369,
footnote 21, they say the atonement
isn't complete until Satan bears the
sins. He will only bear sins that were
confessed. If you forgot any, you won't
make it through the investigative
judgment. So, you'll end up being the
one that bears them. But notice this,
James. This is fundamental to their
position.
It said at toward the beginning, as the
high priest after having cleansed the
sanctuary placed the sins on Aazel.
Question for you. Where does Leviticus
16 say that the scapegoat is Aazel? Can
you show me that in Leviticus 16?
No. What? And this whole Satan and Aazel
and actually applying Aazel as a as a as
a as a pronoun, as a name is completely
incorrect.
Um I mean I've got lots of even Jewish
commentators
do not call Satan um Aazel and it's not
recognizer
place in ancient Neareastern thought it
was where you know demons resided. They
were sending into a wilderness place.
It's not a personal pronoun. It's not
the name of Satan. But notice what it
says here. James
verse starting at verse eight. And Aaron
shall cast lots over the two goats. So
the Lord's goat and the scapegoat. One
lot for the Lord and the other lot for
Aazel. Mhm.
And Aaron shall present the goat on
which the lot fell for the Lord and use
it as a sin offering. But the goat on
which the lot fell for Aazel shall be
presented alive before the Lord to make
atonement over it that it may be sent
away into the wilderness to Aazel.
Right? It's not Satan. It's going to a
place. Where in there does it say the
sins are placed on Satan? It does not
say that. Notice the small slip there in
their footnote
and it's a completely different idea. If
you look at modern translations, which
Keith tried to do this in our debate as
well, and they've tried to do this some
of their scholars recently. No, no, no.
Scapegoat is a modern idea. That's why
it's translated that way is because it's
in modern translations.
No, that excuse isn't going to work. It
depends. It really, James, without
getting too sidetracked into all this
now, it gets into the Maseretic text
versus some of the other manuscripts and
the way that the punctuation falls on
the term Azil and whether or not it's
about a more formal, even like you were
mentioning, if you look at Jewish
scholarship around the more formalities
of it, it's talking about a place. If
anything, it's not talking about an
individual. It's not an entity. Keith
had to appeal to the book of Enoch in
our debate to try and support his idea
of it being a personal individual. So
that is essentially though still part of
the investigative judgment. This is
something that you have to accept as a
part of their gospel.
So um
is that the biblical gospel? Clearly. No
gosh. No. No, it's not. Quickly now I
want to transition into who is the
Adventist Jesus.
Quickly here I want to bring up
we're going to talk about just like we
did with the gospel laying the biblical
foundation. And folks there's a lot of
these by the way. We're going to go
through one right now just for laying
down the framework and the baseline.
Jesus Christ is God Almighty.
And I will show you that. Now, James,
I'm going to ask you to read here for
us.
This is Isaiah 44. If you could read six
through uh 8.
Thus says Yahweh, the king of Israel,
and his redeemer, Yahweh of Host. I am
the first and I am the last, and there
is no God beside me. Who is like me? Let
him call out and declare it, and let him
tell it to me in order from the time
that I established the ancient people,
and let them declare to them the things
that are to come and the events that are
going to take place. Do not be in dread,
and do not be afraid. Have I not long
since caused it to be heard to you and
declared it? And are you my witnesses?
Is there any God beside me, or is there
any other rock? I know of none.
one Yahweh.
That's Lord in some other translations
when your Old Testament is using all
caps L O R D. It is the name of God,
Yahweh. There's only one Lord. He says
one Lord. If we continue in this
talks about Yahweh forgiving and
redeeming, but specifically in in verse
24, can you read that for us, brother?
Verse 24. Yeah. Thus says Yahweh your
redeemer and the one who formed you in
the womb. I Yahweh am the maker of all
things, stretching out my hands,
stretching out the heavens by myself,
and spreading out the earth all alone.
So Yahweh alone created all things.
There's only one Yahweh. God knows of no
other.
Brother, can you read uh we're in
Colossians here. Can you read 15 through
uh 19?
Who is the who is in who is the image of
the invisible God, the firstborn of all
creation? For in him all things were
created, both in the heavens and on
earth, visible and invisible, whether
thrones or dominions or rulers or
authorities. All things have been
created through him and for him.
You want me to read to what? To 19. And
he who is before all things, and in him
all things hold together. And he is the
head of the body, the church, who is the
beginning, the firstborn from the dead,
so that he himself will come to have
first place in everything. For in him
all the fullness of God was pleased to
dwell. Jesus Christ is Yahweh.
The father is Yahweh.
On my channel, we're going to be, like I
said, the direction of the channel is
going to start going into this
direction. Now the trinity why the
language that we use is necessary
adventists. This is why the doctrine of
the trinity which is not to be confused
with the biblical evidence of the
trinity. The doctrine of the trinity is
the language that we use to describe
what we find in the bible. This is why
we have to differentiate between person
and being because in the old testament
you are told and in the new Ephesians
4:5 there is only one lord. Yet, if you
go in the Old Testament, you have the
father being called Lord. And as you
just saw, the one Lord Yahweh made all
things. Jesus Christ made all things
along with the father. So, you have to
have ways to differentiate between what
we're talking about when we say person
and being. This is why it's necessary,
even if there isn't a verse that
explicitly says the father and the son
and the spirit are one being and three
persons. No, we're using language to
explain how this can be the case. You
could do the same thing here. One Lord,
we just read Yahweh, Isaiah 44. If you
go to Mark 1, it says the beginning of
the gospel of Jesus Christ, the son of
God, and what was foretold was he quotes
Isaiah the prophet and says John the
Baptist, that's who it's speaking about,
be the one heralding the message in the
wilderness. He says, "Make way for the
Lord." Isaiah is prophesying about John
the Baptist who would herald the
message, "Make way for the Lord." That's
Jesus Christ. So Jesus Christ is Yahweh.
He is God Almighty. That's the point
with all this. We could also go to John
1. John 1 says the same thing. In the
beginning was the word and the word was
with God. The word was God. He was in
the beginning with God. All things came
into being through him and apart from
him, nothing came into being that has
come into being.
Jesus made all things. We are just told
by Isaiah that Yahweh made all things.
That makes Jesus Christ God Almighty.
So, we could spend the entire rest of
the stream going through all of these
parallels. Jesus forgiving sins, first
Kings 8 saying that it's only God that
can forgive sins, those types of things.
So with that in mind, again, Jesus
Christ is clearly God Almighty.
Adventists may be wondering, well, we
believe that. Okay. Well, now we're
going to get into the Adventist Jesus.
Who is the Adventist Jesus?
Quote. This is from the Spirit of
Prophecy Volume 1, page 17.
This is from their pre-Earth origin
story, folks. For those that don't know,
this is her describing what was taking
place. They have this huge gap between
the creation of heaven and the creation
of earth. That all happened after what
I'm about to read right now, the
creation of earth.
Quote, the great creator, talking about
the father, assembled the heavenly host
that he might in the presence of all the
angels confer special honor upon his
son. The son was seated on the throne
with the father and the heavenly throng
of holy angels was gathered around them.
The father then made known that it was
ordained by himself that Christ his son
should be equal with himself. So that
wherever was the presence of his son, it
was as his own presence. Close quote.
This is what supposedly started the
great controversy. By the way, Lucifer
rebelled because he was jealous that he
thought he should have been the one that
was exalted. What does that tell you
about Jesus? What? What do you mean
Jesus created Lucifer? What do you mean
he makes no sense? You start studying
into this more, you're going to start to
see this seemingly undergirling idea of
Jesus and Satan both being angelic
beings that the father exalted one
causing the other to become jealous and
it started this whole thing.
But at this point too, if you notice,
Jesus was given omnipresence.
Was Yahweh given an omnipresence, James?
No. Uh yeah, this this whole quote you
just read, it's
it's it's like, you know, the father and
the son are so separate and that the the
father now is bestowing upon his son
special powers and which the Bible
quotes we just read prove that did not
happen. No, you know, Christ is the
fullness of God and has been since the
beginning. He didn't get bestowed
special powers before creation. And
every time I read this, I am so thinking
of Mormonism. I mean, there's a quote in
Mormonism that I like to use all the
time because the Mormons call. They call
Jesus and Lucifer were spirit brothers.
Now, the average Mormon that they flip a
lid. They go, "What do you mean Jesus
and Lucifer were spirit?" Yeah. Well,
that's what it says in your gospel, uh,
I think it's called Gospel, not Gospel,
uh, a gospel through the ages by Milton
Hunter. And, and I'm looking at a quote
here um, from Ellen White. It says,
"Satan was once an honored angel in
heaven next to Christ." I mean, yeah,
she uses that all the time. Next to
That's like calling him an angel. You're
doing the same thing. Um, so yeah,
here's a second quote on that same
thing. Like, folks, this isn't in just
one place. She's saying this over and
over and over. Patriarchs and Prophets,
one of the big three, page 37. quote,
"The exaltation of the Son of God as
equal with the Father
was represented as an injustice to
Lucifer, who it was claimed was also
entitled to reverence and honor."
No, Yahweh was not exalted to be equal
with Yahweh.
Sorry folks, this is why in this is
Adventist. I I cannot stress this enough
to you. You have to stop being paranoid
about, oh, the the historic church was
using Greek philosophy. And no, folks,
they were in a Greek society. That'd be
like people looking back 300 years from
now on anything you guys have said and
saying, "Oh, that's American
philosophy." Faulting you for using
language of your own day. What else are
you supposed to use? Duh. It's not them
porting into the Bible things that are
not there. It's them using language to
describe this. This is why you have to
have a proper understanding of the
trinity.
You can't have the son who is Yahweh,
the spirit who is Yahweh, which I can
also show from scripture as well, and
the father as Yahweh, which I can also
show a scripture from as well, but then
have things like Jesus's baptism where
all three persons are present. You have
to have a way to word that where it's
one God, but clearly three distinguished
persons, the ability to will,
self-reflect, speak, show emotions, etc.
But this next quote, brother, this this
one is just
causes me to flip a lid. And the
Adventists want to defend this. Well,
we'll get into how they they try and
defend this, but remember the verses we
just read, folks, from scripture. This
is from Lift Him Up, page 253.
Quote, "There is no one who can explain
the mystery of the incarnation of
Christ." I agree.
Yet we know that he came to this earth
and lived as a man among men.
The man Christ Jesus was not the Lord
God Almighty.
Yet Christ and the Father are one.
The deity did not sink under the
agonizing torture of Calvary. Yet it is
nonetheless true that God so loved the
world that he gave his only begotten son
that whosoever believeth in him should
not perish but have everlasting life.
Close quote.
Yes, Jesus Christ is the Lord God
Almighty. Now, the excuse they try to
give to this is no, no, no, no, no. She
was trying to differentiate between him
not being the father.
That's not a way you distinguish between
the father and son. Adventists, you
don't distinguish between the father and
son by saying one is the lord god
almighty, the other is not.
This is again if you understand
systematically their system of theology
or what Ellen was saying her system it's
this idea
that Jesus Christ is a lesser than the
father. This is at a time period too
before the the their understanding of
the Holy Spirit even having a
personality. The Holy Spirit was just
like an energy or a force that proceeded
from the it was like the presence of the
father and the son proceeding
essentially from them. It wasn't even a
person.
But as we saw earlier,
and there are far more than that, Jesus
Christ is the Lord God Almighty. Even if
that was what Ellen was doing, saying
that it's the father, a differentiation
between the father and the son. It's an
invalid differentiation and it shows
that she did not understand who Christ
is. Ephesians 4:5, there's only one
Lord.
You can't have the Lord God Almighty,
but Jesus Christ is also the Lord.
That's two Lords.
This is why properly understanding the
Trinity is important, Adventists, and
why I'm going to be starting putting out
content around this. But something we
need to focus on here really quick. Um,
by the term one, this is a key phrase
for them. They like to point to say the
father, the G, Jesus, and the father are
one. We have to get into the definitions
around that. By one, they mean that they
are one in their mission, purpose, and
character.
But that's not what makes a singular
god, though.
James, do you know by chance where I am
getting this from? No, I know. I I read
it earlier. So, I'm going to bring up a
paper here. This is from Jerry Moon.
Tell the audience who Jerry Moon is if
you haven't. He is an instructor of
theology
uh for Seventh Day Adventist. So he is,
you know, the one responsible for
teaching
many pastors that are working today.
Yep. And is he still working? I believe
so. I believe he is still a chair of
church history at Andrews University.
Yeah, this is a paper one of of a number
that he's done on this topic
about the history and evolving position
of trinitarian what they call
trinitarianism within the 7th day
advenist church. Again, this guy is a
scholar in the 7th adventist church.
He's one of the leading 7th day
Adventist church historians in the
seventh advenist church. Can you read
that highlighted portion for us there,
James? Yeah. The term person as applied
to God indicates a being with
personality, intellect, and will. Unlike
the multiple gods of polytheism, the
three persons of the biblical godhead
are profoundly
one in purpose, in mind, in character,
but not in person. Thus, despite their
individuality, they are never divided,
never in conflict, and thus constitute
not three gods, but one god. So, how are
they defining a single god?
Yeah, because they're not because
they're not divided. So, they use this
example of like the pantheon, how you
have all these different beings. And
notice what he says there. The term
person is applied to applied to God
indicates a being with personality,
intellect, and will. So, you have a
person and being. So, you have three
persons, three beings. Adventists, when
I've said this on the channel and you
guys have tried to argue with me, there
it is. There it is. Don't say that I'm
just making this up, that I'm
misrepresenting. Have you read your own
scholars papers? Are you digging into
this stuff?
So, right there you have three persons,
three beings. But he says, unlike the
multiple gods of polytheism,
the three persons of the biblical
godhead. So, the compare and contrast is
not that it's a singular being.
It's that there's no division amongst
them. So in the parthonon, you have all
these Zeus and all them. They're all
fighting with one another. So that's
what makes multiple gods, the fighting.
But because the godhead of the Bible is
not fighting like that, it makes them
one god.
No, you have three gods here. That's
fundamentally what's being said. I know
that he says it's not three gods, but
one god. But the way that one is being
described and the word the way the word
god is being used,
you have what's consistent again and he
goes into on this paper and another one
talking about how this idea of the
trinity that they've evolved and landed
on was informed essentially by biblical
study but the writings of Ellen White
which were given superiority around the
heavenly trio the three worthies that
sort of thing. So that's from their own
scholar. That's how they define person.
That's how they define God being one.
They're not divided like the pantheon in
disagreement. So that makes them one
singular God.
No, that's not what makes like James,
are you and I one person and one being
uh or
you know, whatever analogy there you
want to use because you and I are united
in our mission with the gospel, right?
There's still a separateness. Yeah.
There's not a singularess with
plurality. The difference with between
with God and us is that God isn't like
anything in creation. Nothing can be all
these analogies that people try to use,
they all fall short. Um, and so they're
off on this. We're not we're not getting
into the trinity tonight. That'll be for
a separate time. But that's how they're
defining one God and one person. This is
a quote from Ellen White, The Spirit of
Prophecy, Volume 2, page 9.
Quote, "The Son of God was next in
authority to the great lawgiver.
Yahweh was in next in authority to
Yahweh.
He knew that his life alone could be
sufficient to ransom fallen men. He was
of as much more value than man as his
noble spotless character and exalted
office as commander of all the heavenly
host were above the work of man. He was
in the express image of his father not
in features alone but in perfection of
character.
She says here which this is again
another topic and Jerry talks about that
in that same paper how they define
person which we didn't get into. Well,
he he did a little bit there, but they
define that as a tangible physical form.
The father, the son, the holy spirit all
have physical tangible forms. And the
son of God was next in authority to the
great lawgiver. Again, you have Jesus
being some sort of subservient.
Yeah. He's God's backup man. Here you
have Jesus is a separate being.
Patriarchs and Prophets page 34.
The sovereign of the universe, meaning
the father, was not alone in his work of
beneficence. He had an associate,
a co-orker who could appreciate his
purposes and could share his joy in
giving happiness to created beings.
Christ the Word, the only begotten of
God, was one with the eternal father,
one in nature, in character, in purpose,
the only being that could enter into all
the councils and purposes of God.
Close quote. So, hold on, hold on, hold
on. Again, folks, think about what we
just read from scripture. And that's
only one place I'm telling you, I can
show you over and over and over and over
that Jesus Christ is Yahweh, the
fullness of God.
She differentiates Jesus from the
sovereign. Says he's a separate being.
And if Christ is the only being able to
enter into these councils, James,
what about the Holy Spirit?
Either he isn't a being or he's lesser
being because he's not able to enter
into all of this. You have s you have
Lucifer being next to Jesus. Where's the
Holy Spirit in all of this?
This was written at a time when their
idea of the Holy Spirit was that it was
again a force sent forth by the father
and the son, not a person.
She says, she goes into further detail
on the same thing. A little bit of a
longer quote, Spirit of Prophecy, Volume
1, page 18.
Quote, Satan was envious and jealous of
Jesus Christ. Christ had been taken into
the special counsel of God in regard to
his plans. While Satan was unacquainted
with them, he did not understand,
neither was he permitted to know the
purposes of God. But Christ was
acknowledged the sovereign of heaven.
His power and authority to be the same
as that of God himself.
Well, wait. Jesus is God himself.
Satan thought that he was himself a
favorite in heaven among the angels. He
had been highly exalted, but this did
not call forth from him gratitude and
praise to his creator. He aspired to the
height of God himself. He glorified in
his loftiness. He knew that he was
honored by the angels. He had a special
mission to execute. He had been near the
great creator. Again, that next to near
language, and the ceaseless beams of
glorious light enshrouding the eternal
God had shown especially upon him. Satan
thought how angels had obeyed his
command with pleasurable elacrity.
Were not his garments light and
beautiful? Why should Christ thus be
honored before himself?
Close quote.
Brother, what
what are your thoughts when you hear
this stuff as a Christian? You know, um
these are some of the most sickening
doctrines
u that you're you're just ever going to
hear. Same kind of stuff you're going to
hear in Mormonism. It's just yeah,
utterly blasphemous.
Um and and and it needs to be called out
and it needs to be called exactly what
it is. As you said earlier, 7th day
Adventism, you have a different Christ.
And you quoted 2 Corinthians 11:3 and4
where the Apostle Paul is anguishing
over the Corinthians. I'm afraid if
someone comes and preaches another
Christ to you, you're going to believe
it. Well, you know, 7th Day Adventist,
it's it's happened to you. Another
Christ has been preached to you and you
believe it. But if you're a 7th Day
Adventist and you're here right now,
you are now hearing the truth and you're
going to be held accountable for that.
You need to act on what you've heard cuz
now you can you're no longer without
excuse. You've heard the evidence.
You've seen the scriptures and you've
seen them compared to Ellen White and
they fail. You have another Christ. I
mean, I'm sitting here looking on my
screen at quotes that that Miles hasn't
even had a chance to bring up yet. We
could we could do this for another three
more hours. You know, Jesus has a sinful
nature. Ellen White said Jesus is a
coward. Uh Jesus has brothers, older
brothers. I thought he was born of a
virgin. I mean, on and on and on. All
this they'll say to that. They'll
they'll say to that the whole Joseph,
Joseph stepchildren and
Give me that scripture verse for that.
By the way, I've only got a couple more
quotes here and then I'll let you finish
off with any others that you have. Um,
I've got about three here. This last
one's a little long, but again, further
building on this idea,
Jesus convinced the father after trying
three times that he would be the
sacrifice for humanity.
This is from
Spirit of Prophecy Volume 1 page 45.
Quote, "Sorrowfilled heaven as it was
realized that man was lost." This is her
commentating on after the fall of man.
And the world that God created was to be
filled with mortals doomed to misery,
sickness, and death. And there was no
way of escape for the offender. The
whole family of Adam must die. I saw the
lovely Jesus and beheld an expression of
sympathy. So, she saw Jesus.
For those that aren't aren't aware, you
want to know who the last human being
was to see the Lord Jesus Christ? Ellen
G. White. Supposedly,
that's the last person, James, to
supposedly
physically see the Lord Jesus. She
claimed to be taken up to heaven
multiple times. Yeah, many times. Just
VIP treatment, just ushered in. Nothing
like the experience of falling on the
ground in absolute agony at your
sinfulness, your fallenness, your
unworthiness. No, no, no, no. She's
ushered in like it's a a beach resort.
Right. Right. On VIP status that other
people don't have. The whole family of
Adam must die. I saw the lovely Jesus
and beheld an expression of sympathy and
sorrow upon his countenance. Soon I saw
him approach the exceeding bright light
which enshrouded the father. Said my
accompanying angel. He is in close
converse with his father. The anxiety of
the angels seemed to be intense while
Jesus was communing with his father.
Three times he was shut in by the
glorious light about the father. And the
third time he came from the father his
person could be seen.
His countenance was calm, free from all
perplexity and trouble and shown with
benevolence and loveliness such as words
cannot express. He then made known to
the angelic host that the way of escape
had been made for lost man. He told them
that he had been pleading with his
father and had offered to give his life
a ransom and take the sentence of death
upon himself, that through him man might
find pardon, that through the merits of
his blood and obedience to the law of
God, they could have the favor of God
and be brought into the beautiful garden
and eat of the tree of life.
Close quote. The blood of Christ isn't
sufficient enough to save, but his blood
and perfect obedience to the ten
commandments are. The law, yes, the law
of God for them is the ten commandments
for those that don't know. But notice
this
division in the godhead. The son had to
convince the father.
This is a very human way of speaking
about God.
this and and you can read the history
around this around how James White they
hated the trinitarian creeds because
they felt that God wasn't personal
personable enough so they made him more
essentially into the likeness of man
right that's division in the godhead
folks Jesus did not convince the father
he's the lamb slain from the foundation
of the world Ephesians 1 this was not an
afterthought this did not take God by
surprise and oh no he had to have a
special counsel to figure out what he's
going to too.
Absolutely crazy.
Again, Jesus presented the plan of
redemption to the father and he had to
be convinced of executing it. Spirit of
prophecy, volume 1, page 47. Jesus bade
the heavenly host be reconciled to the
plan that his father accepted
and rejoice that fallen man could be
exalted again through his death to
obtain favor with God and enjoy heaven.
We just heard what that favor with God
is. How does one get that? the blood of
Christ plus obedience to the Ten
Commandments.
I got two more here. I'm telling you,
this is right out of Mormonism. Yeah. It
It's straight out of Mormonism, which is
probably 30 miles from Rochester where
Ellen was living. Yep.
Manuscript number 347
I.8.
Christ bore the sins of the whole world.
He endured our punishment, the wrath of
God against transgression. His trivial
invol or his trial involved the fierce
temptation of thinking that he was
forsaken by God. His soul was tortured
by the pressure of a horror of great
darkness less he should swerve from his
uprightness during the terrible ordeal.
He could have sinned, right?
He could not have been tempted in all
points like as man is tempted had there
been no possibility of his falling.
Yahweh, folks, Yahweh. Yahweh.
He was a free agent placed on probation.
This gets into their whole idea of man
being on probation and Christ coming and
and being on probation as well to and
that whole thing. He was a free agent
placed on probation as was Adam is as
man.
or sorry, he was a free agent placed on
probation as was Adam and as is man.
Unless there is a possibility of
yielding, temptation is no temptation. I
get this from Adventists all the time.
They don't understand the the reason for
the temptations. Temptation comes and is
resisted when man is powerfully
influenced to do a wrong action and
knowing that he can do it, resists by
faith with a firm hold upon divine
power. This was the ordeal through which
Christ passed. Close quote. Christ could
have sinned,
right? He could have sinned because as
Bible reading for the home circle says
in 1916,
in his humanity, Christ partook of our
sinful fallen nature. That's a fact.
I've got that quote as well. So, we got
sin in the God Godhead.
Blasphemous, man. Go. Yeah. Go figure.
Blasphemous. Yeah.
In fact, James, and I've I've posted
about this on my channel, and
Adventists, of course, flock there and
say, "There's no sin there." Adventists,
this is why I'm concerned for you guys.
Seriously, this is why I'm concerned
because you hear stuff like what I'm
about to read, this final quote to end
on and then whatever else you have,
brother. This is all my notes.
Well, I'm just going to read it and then
we'll talk about it.
This is Desire of Ages page 753.
Satan with his fierce temptations
rung the heart of Jesus. Twisted the
heart of Jesus. The Savior could not see
through the portals of the tomb.
Hope did not present to him his coming
forth from the grave a conqueror or tell
him of the father's acceptance of the
sacrifice. He feared that sin was so
offensive to God that their separation
was to be eternal. Close quote. Satan
manipulated the mind of Yahweh, causing
him to doubt.
Never mind that he said in, you know,
John 2, which Adventists love to say,
"No, no, he he did prophesy about his
resurrection." Okay. Well, you've got
contradictions here then. Who you going
to roll with? The Bible or this? Jesus
doubted Jesus doubted. Yahweh doubted
his resurrection. because Satan was able
to twist his heart causing him to do
that. Do you understand what doubt is,
Adventists?
That means he wasn't trusting the father
fully. He came to do the father's will.
To say that he doubted is a sin. It's
unbelief. It means that Jesus had
unbelief.
This is blasphemous heresy. You need to
flee from this. You need to give it up.
It's time to give it up, folks. It's
time to give it up.
It's time to get serious about this.
Stop with the games.
Stop with I understand we were James, I
know, was not a former Adventist, but
former Adventists were there. We were
there. We understand it's difficult.
It's hard. You have to give up a lot for
this. These are serious matters. This is
the Jesus of Seventh Day Adventism. You
can say, "Oh, I never read Ellen White."
This is what is informing the theology
of the Seventh Day Adventist
Institution.
My pastor never mentions Ellen White.
Well, be on the lookout for the channel
in the coming weeks because I'm going to
show you how they work it in and don't
tell you
whether knowingly or habitually. Some of
these guys like Doug Bachelor, I think
he's just been saying it so long. He's
one of these where the line between
Ellen and the Bible is just so blurred
he doesn't even know.
That's all I got in my notes, brother.
if you have any other quotes to share.
Um, just a couple thoughts. You we
started this whole night off with
talking about why be concerned about 7th
Day Adventists? Are they just another
Christian religion? And you just gave a
quote, "Mipulative Satan from the Desire
of the Ages." And guess what? You know
what Adventists do when they go out on
missionary? What books do they hand out?
Great controversy. Patriarchs and
Prophets desire pages. the big books,
the Conflicts of the Ages series. Yeah.
So, you just quoted this heretical
doctrine from a book that is routinely
handed out by Seventh Day Adventists.
And so, for you 7th Day Adventists that
Miles was just talking to, you're on the
fence. Well, my pastor doesn't do this.
My church doesn't do that. This year, I
heard Wilson says, is uh great
controversy 2.0. Yep. trying to get out
a billion. Yeah. Yeah. Billion,
including digital. Yes. They're going to
handle the great controversy. And we've
already quoted tonight several heretical
quotes from the great controversy. And
that's not even the tip of the iceberg,
folks. No, no, no, no, no. So, you're a
member of a church who hands out her
books full of heretical quotes. You just
heard one from the Desire of the Ages.
You've heard several tonight from The
Great Controversy.
Uh, this woman is frankly Ellen White is
just not to be trusted or read. And like
Miles said, well, my church never
mentions a lot. Well, she owns a chapter
in this book.
She's the
She's the mark whenever they downplay
Ellen White, they're downplaying being
the remnant. Fundamental belie.
Yeah. Fundamental belief number 18 says
that the mark of the remnant church is
the spirit of prophecy which they
believe was manifested in the ministry
of LG White. Yeah. Don't play these
games. That's also part of the reason I
started this channel, James. I got so
sick of the games. Adventists, own up to
what you actually teach and believe.
Yeah. Own up to it. Don't play these
games. Just own up to it. At least some
of these other groups like the Jehovah's
Witnesses and the Mormons, not all of
them, but I've engaged with a lot of
them. James, I've been doing like you
have. I've been doing on the street
evangelism for like eight years now.
I've run into all sorts of people. The
Hari Krishna, Jehovah's Witnesses, the
Pelagians, a guy who who goes out to the
local park here in Nashville that thinks
he's the reincarnation of Elisha the
prophet. I mean, dude, I've run into all
sorts of stuff.
These people are at least most of the
time when I engage with them honest
about what they teach and believe. It's
the Adventists who I consistently engage
with who they always want to play these
games. Like you said earlier, not all of
them. I I want to preface this by saying
there are lots of great people in the
Seventh Advenist Church, folks. I grew
up in the Seventh Advenist Church. My
dad is a pastor in the Seventh Advenist
Church. I have lots of amazing memories
in the Seventh Advenist Church. I'm not
saying that you're all evil people, but
this is serious. This is a serious
problem.
Hello. You're going toward the cliff and
we're here tonight. You can shoot the
messenger all you want, but I hope the
words from tonight ring in your ears and
keep you up at night and cause you to
think if I die, I'm going to go to hell.
Because that's the thought that God
pressed on me when I realized I'm worthy
of damnation. I'm not holy enough to
make it on my own. It doesn't matter any
works that I do. Nothing can add to what
Jesus Christ has already done. That
doesn't mean that you don't follow out
in obedience as sanctification begins to
take place, etc. But these are some
serious, serious heretical issues. And
like you said, we only scratched the
surface tonight. Yeah. But they want to
play these games oftent times where no,
no, no, we're just like you or like you
mentioned earlier, we don't believe
that. Then you quote it, then they start
defending it. I had this happen today
three times. It's just like, well, hold
up. I thought you just said you guys
don't teach and believe this. Now you're
defending it. You're defending something
you don't teach and believe. Just own up
to what you guys believe, man. Just own
up to what you believe. How you know
Seventh Day Adventism wins over biblical
truth. Yep. It's not commitment to the
Lord Jesus Christ at all costs. Whatever
it wherever the truth leads. Jesus
Christ is the way, the truth, and the
life. I was willing to go wherever the
truth led. It does not lead to Seventh
Day Adventism. I'm telling you that. We
know that. We just saw it tonight,
brother. No. Unless you believe that
there's no perspu scripture. You can't
just understand
what we read tonight.
Okay. Well, then at that point, I don't
even think you have business being a
Christian, claiming to believe the Bible
or any of that because you may as well
just go back to you may as well go to
Rome where they're going to tell you you
need it. Well, in Adventism, you do
essentially have that. You have Ellen to
tell you um what the scriptures actually
mean and teach. she functions as the
infallible interpreter of scripture and
um but then at the same time you've
engaged with them enough um you have to
have an infallible interpreter for the
infallible interpreter of the infallible
scriptures. It's like John Ankerberg
said on the John Ankerberg show with
with uh Walter Martin and um William
Johnson. It's like William he was
listening there for those that don't
know John Edgarberg was the host. It was
his show. This is in like the 70s or the
80s. And he's like, "Well, it sounds to
me like you're saying you need an
infallible interpreter for the
infallible interpreter because William
Johnson tried to play these same games
with Walter Martin when he was quoting
stuff." Well, you're misrepresenting.
You don't understand. And just by
observing
uh Ankerberg is like, "Well, it sounds
like we can't even understand the
infallible interpreter on our own. We
need you to help us interpret the
infallible interpreter." And so that's
all like I said I had tonight, brother,
unless you have anything else. Do you
have anything else to share? No, no, I
don't. Uh, thank you once again for for
having me here to chat with you. Plug
your plug your YouTube channel. Let
people know where they can find your
information at. Let them know what your
channel is uh about and then uh we'll
sign off for the night. Yeah. So, you
can find me. It's one string, no space
in between it. Academy Apollia.
And I got a video dropping tonight. I'm
going to start a whole series on Daniel
chapter 7. Oh, excellent. I want to I
want to reclaim for the former Adventist
any aversions you may have to reading
the book of Daniel. And the first video
that's going to drop is about uh it's
going to tackle Ellen's chron biblical
chronological chart that you're all
familiar with where the papacy ascended
to power in 538 AD and ended in 1798 AD.
And that's bunch of nonsense. And I'm
going to show you how the biblical
chart's going to go down. And I got a
series of videos coming out on Daniel
7:25.
Yeah. So, for those that are curious,
his uh I just want to bring this up here
real quick so people can see this is his
channel.
Academy Apolla Gia.
Brother, thank you so much for being
here tonight. I hope that the training
God will use this to draw a people to
himself. Um trusting that God is
faithful. the true and living God who
knows his people, who is saving his
people. Um, I pray that he uses this
like we did before stream to draw a
people to himself. Um, so thank you so
much for being here. Thank you for your
time and uh we'll be talking to you uh
in the future. Absolutely. And just one
final note, I just pray the Holy Spirit
convicts you 7th Day Adventists that are
either listening with us live or even
later of the biblical truths that have
been presented to you tonight.
Amen. Thank you, brother. All right.
Thank you.
So, folks, like I said, this stream
tonight was not Kid Gloves.
It wasn't PC.
That is not this channel. If you're
looking for that, this ain't the right
place. There's a time and a place for
everything. Some of you guys have
emailed me, messaged me, we've talked on
the phone, those type things. I'm not
always this way, but there is a time and
a place for something like this. The
information that you heard tonight is
serious.
If you're an Adventist and you say,
"Well, I don't believe those things. I
know she said that, but I don't believe
those things." Get out of an
organization that does. Don't be a part
of a organization that's going to
proitize literature. that's going to
promote those ideas. It's confusing
people.
It's confusing people.
It's time to give this up. It's time to
give this up. Come to a
accept the truth as was presented
tonight. I know that some of you are
going to say, "Oh, you're taking that
out of context. It's going to be the
same things I've always heard." I
understand that. I understood that
before I even started this channel,
folks. I've been engaging with
Adventists for a long time. I didn't
come into this with my eyes wide shut.
But I know that there are some
Adventists that are going to hear this.
Whether today, tomorrow, a year from
now, 10 years from now, you're like, I
was. You're not voicing it.
But you know something doesn't add up.
You're going to see the thing tonight,
this this dream from tonight.
You're going to examine these things for
yourself. like the Christians in Berea
that Paul mentions in Thessalonians who
tested even the things that the inspired
apostle said up and against the word of
God and you're going to do that same
thing and there's going to be something
within you that convicts you.
Give into that folks
trust. Pray to the trying God and say,
"God, show me the truth. I want to know
the truth." He will lead you. He will
guide you. I promise.
If you liked tonight's stream, please be
so kind as to smash that like button. It
really helps the channel. If you could
subscribe and ring the notification bell
as well, so you can be notified when
content like this is uploaded. Um, like
I said, this is the direction that the
channel is going to be heading in in the
next few weeks. There's going to be some
sporadic stuff uh
scattered throughout there, some really
micro content type stuff just to convey
some single points, but this is the
topics that are we're going to be
addressing now on the channel. There
have been some people who have been
saying things like this channel doesn't
even get into scripture.
For those that are new, for those that
don't know, the bio of this channel says
what this channel's about. The video on
the cover page of the channel says what
this channel is about. This channel
first and foremost is a saint equipping
resource. It is about Christians. As you
heard tonight, I do not consider 7th
Adventist Christians. This website is
not some pioneer thing where I'm
exposing Seventh Day Adventism and I'm a
pioneer. No, no.
I am presenting a lot of information
that's already out there. It's not
unique to me. Lots of people have been
saying this stuff before I was saying
it. This website or this YouTube channel
is a saint equipping resource to equip
God's church to be better under like
learned and understood about a very
complex movement because I have a unique
positioning having grown up in this
church being educated in their
institutions. My father's a pastor in
the church. So I am feeling called to
equip God's church to better equip the
saints who come across seventh day
Adventists to not be so in the dark and
understand the real issues to be able to
dialogue with them. I am not a preacher.
I'm not an online Bible teacher. That's
not what this channel is about. Yeah, we
talk about Ellen White a lot because
believe it or not, all of SDA theology
is downstream of Ellen White. It's
important for Christians to understand
those things and understand where these
ideas are coming from.
So, in the coming weeks, we're going to
be getting into the deity of Christ, the
Adventist Jesus, breaking down some of
the things that we talked about tonight
in even more granular detail, and we're
going to camp out on this area as long
as is necessary. It's going to include
talking about who is Christ, what is the
gospel, the great controversy, the
investigative judgment. We're going to
start diving into a lot of these things.
So again, if you like content like that,
please subscribe and ring that
notification bell so you can be
notified. Um, as of right now, I don't
have any other live streams uh
scheduled, but more will be coming in
the future. Um, some of you have
requested stuff with EJ and CMB, the
ambassador. Uh, more of that is also
definitely coming. Um, so stay tuned for
all that stuff. Thanks so much for
tuning in tonight. I appreciate you guys
and until next time, as always, God
bless.
[Music]